sous nos yeux est-ce que tu as la petite
goutte sur le front n'ont pu être très
sec et serein alors c'est un double
grand jour déjà grand jour parce que
maxime le grand prix jérusalem qu'on
attend depuis maintenant un an j'ai
envie de dire mais aussi l'anniversaire
d'aaland c'est vrai le gange
le plongeon fait quoi là il fête ses 50
ans et il est toujours là
moi je dis ça je dis rien que boîte il
le matin sûrement de l'autre c'est des
stocks bas je pense aussi je pense qu'il
est assez petite fiole comme el pueblo
quoi et il est là il voit ses petites
fioles et il reste en forme donc c'est
le secret de jouvence de vichy qui est
toujours là rend clairement que la
réclame donc fable tu as un petit peu lu
çà et là le tableau tu en penses quoi
en général nous partons de maths ce
parcours de maxime by tout premier tour
c'est mervin il est bien tombée quoi
topalov c'est pas fun terreur pas se
dire qu'il a déjà éliminé deux fois sur
deux dans l'exemple précédent et il est
vite il évite des gros clash jusqu'aux
demi-finales quoi donc bon tirage
bon tirage mais qu'en même temps par la
fin de vers serre dangereux non en bon
état sont apparemment de peintre c'est
toujours ces grands prix enfin c'est que
des mecs à plus de 1700 donc ok ça peut
pas être un cadeau
topalov toute façon on sait comment ils
jouent il va te faire e all in et
évidemment une fois de temps en temps ça
peut passer
il vous faut quand même faut quand même
être vigilant c'est pas gagné d'avancé
mais si tu me donnes le choix avant le
tournoi si je peux choisir entre jouer
topaloff ou est ce vaisseau ou car
yakine tu vois hein c'est juste le
martyr je peux avoir avec nos portes
ben moi je moi j'aurais choisi 1 400
jeunes jouent personnes oui moi aussi
mais bon c'est au fait de jouer des
joueurs de la liste du tournoi est ce
que tu as fait j'ai fait une petite
prière pour daniel reyne quoi ah oui
j'ai vu je me suis vu le truc trop
bavarde et bon appariement quoi enfin un
os daniel reyne
dujardin richard il discute préfère juin
15 cents à navarra bon là c'est vrai que
fo question la question
question piège quoi oui je préfère
qu'elle joue et navara ou 6e queen ne
connaîtra plus pour que quinson c'est
pas un peu ni peu avec des dvd de
qualité ou quoi on ne sait pas du tout
quelqu'un pourrait indiquer la cadence
et du long c'est le 2e c'est la très bon
c'est quoi c'est une heure 40 30
secondes et un rajout au 40e c'est ça
ouais je suis paumé un truc comme ça
mais sachant les talents des nouvelles
cadences à chaque wilaya le rajout ici
royale rajput car voilà c'est pas du
délai c'est la limite kasparov le délai
attention ce qui tue au 6 rue de télé
quand même je vous renvoie pas le reste
du délai on a voulu faire un truc
original en fait c'est bon ouais donc le
tableau de max il est plutôt pas mal
je pense qu'on est beau et en sueur au
tirage alors attendez peau il joua temps
il fut contraint de m'arrêter au premier
nommé google phone
bon ok c'est pas que ces duos
spécialement plus ou pas sa farce
évidente
admettons mais le tour d'après il va se
prendre soho new skies et de bas mais
non c'est pas évident je pense que l'epo
je vois pas loin ma mais il peut il peut
par contre il a convié deux tableaux il
peut il peut plus que pouvoir parce
qu'ils jouent au premier tour iakovenko
c'est fou
oui mais voilà ça va bien sûr deuxième
tour il aura soin car yakine soirée
krishna ont deux joueurs qui jouent
potentiellement pas grand chose et est
en demies ça peut être sauf à des mecs
qui jouera un plus geri voisinage et
bissau ses dirigeants
wallace donc ma mais attention voilà
c'était plutôt mal mais l'homme à
surveiller plus sinon évidemment on sait
jamais un des mecs bons qui sont très
loin mais qui peut être outillés que moi
je cassais coup ou sommet j'y crois pas
trop on a très peu de chances que je tue
en ou d'ighirri va sortir mam et en
demie alors à moi déjà je dirais que
geri va pas aller en denis faye s'est
fait éliminer par daniel double offre
quand même bon j'ai envie de te dire de
faux maintenant c'est à dire que là ils
arrivent ici oui
vais je passer le premier tour jouera
grosse question pour guiry cvg éliminé
navarra coiffe un fou et amaigri il peut
juste faire deux nuls permet des rapides
et entre chez nous comme ça il a sur son
vélo et sur sa qualité mais il va se
reposer
voilà panier très heureux de tout non
ouais ouais pas guérit pas mais tu sais
jamais s'il a envie de faire le tournoi
bon mais je vois pas en quel honneur il
serait très motivé pour jouer sa hache
et catalans guy daniel dubois fait un
sacré client tout de même il ya en
dessous de 1700 ans tu as j'ai envie de
dire non mais on est ok tout buzz
dangereux mais mais voilà deux boîtiers
de 1670 super complet au premier tour
c'est bien qu'ils avaient sorti le jour
dans le chalet guie guie guie
ce repas ch'ti autre courte salon fait
marrer il avait fait fait prendre un fou
rire avec sangria
alors oui je vois bien j'aurai la salle
représente tellement en plus non mais
excellent allait s'en vont des fois dans
le chat des voix et des fois même
souvent mais souvent elles comptent
encore 6 à 8 on attend à tanger des
motifs sur le téléphone je les garde au
début l'histoire de de vérifier s'il ya
des problèmes
non là c'est juste une fille qui publie
sur instagram ça va on souffre et dont
tu vois des photos
bah c'est génial d'être connecté
instagram très vite avant le life lui
très important que j'exerçais
non m qui marche ça va probablement fait
la fille je peux prouver les no fake
mais aujourd'hui ces manifs de la nand
aura-t-on le droit des cris de dauphin
de pousser ce chiffre c'est votre fric
de dauphin menaces extérieures
j'ai écouté comme tout ce que je vois
jouer un tournoi jaurès j'attende zite
note qui serait fausse stressé et chats
registre c'est beau mais dieu seul sait
si c'est vrai quoi c'est une histoire de
vlad donc vous très dangereux quoi c'est
pas dans mais il a dit que michael
confirmé quand même ça veut rien dire
hélène valade qui a dit que kramnik
avait confié d'ailleurs il ya double qui
jouent contre éric en scène là sur une
chaise comme moi je regarde sa partie
d'athlètes quoi j'ai à perdre contre 30
cents us à être heureux après c'est une
grippe
guigui maintenant qu'on sait qui tu
prépares maintenant qu'on sait qui tu ce
bouffon groupe non mais je sais pas et
ce qu'ils abattent rendre c'est nous pas
fin pour le vent il ya deux ans et demi
deux ans et demi comme l envie de te
dire match très serré ouais bah du coup
ils ragent où il amène de l'eau à la
porte de la notre moulin quoi nouveau x
qui est pas venir quand ça n'en fait non
mais il est très fort du beauf mais
enfin c'est pas comment les préparer
après c'est très bien mais alors ça vous
inquiète pas de wild card pour mac se
réserver un russe a annoncé par l'afe
des rues soient là bas ça va en fait
j'ai envie de te dire on n'était pas
dans les petits papiers de de la fédé
russe mais fabre ça fait honnêtement ça
fait un an que j'en parle de ça non non
non du tout content je dirais on le
savait de toute façon je ne peux pas ce
truc chez stream et en a marre oui mais
bon enfin c'est tout à fait normal mais
voilà quoi ce pas tabou dans mes balades
il a mis la bonne punchline conseil que
les allemands l'avaient donné à lutz
quand même
[Musique]
christopher lutz un palmarès personne ne
le connaît qua non à les verser non mais
de base pour faire court on préférerait
tout ce qui est juste un intérêt sportif
et qui est pas doué le carte du tout
mais le truc c'est que c'est déjà
difficile dans l'état actuel des choses
de 3,1 organisateurs qui veulent bien
faire donc d'objets de données carottes
quoi ça en plus âgés ce j'ai senti que
les gens étaient semi heureux sur
twitter et/ou en france que la russie
soit sanctionné qui puisse peut-être
plus organiser les candidats bon alors
que c'est ça bon déjà les vols organisés
et déjà des pas de quoi être
spécialement heureux non mais j'ai en
moi je suis plutôt déçu pour les
sportifs russes
évidemment il ya le problème de dopage
etc qui était organisé par la russie et
ça c'est vrai tu vas cesser complètement
anormal etc c'est grave et même les
russes les potes plus que j'ai il trouve
que c'est grave aussi quoi mais mais je
veux dire en soi on peut pas on peut pas
se réjouir de ça a failli heurter russie
plein de gens honnêtes qui se retrouvent
bloqués à cause d'un système failli sont
pour rien en fait les individus un
moment mais après ils peuvent courir
concourir sous des bannières neutre
ouais mais de là à interdire
l'organisation des machins est ou non
mais surtout que propose de choc il ya
pas de problème de triche aux échelles
ouais mais ils pourront ils pourront
concourir mais ils pourront pas défendre
leur pays quoi enfin je trouve ça quand
même un peu enfin non mais ok si
vraiment obligés d'agir si elle vraiment
ses cheveux non pourquoi on n'agit pas
contre les coureurs kényans par exemple
ben moi je sais enfin cette piste
médiatique de faire sa ba oui fin
jarrier eu plein de problèmes plein de
fois dans l'histoire de ce sport c'est
pas nouveau et met donc la bande ku à
deux façons pour les candidats et où sa
longue date et non mais bon joueur je
trouve que ça va un peu loin
puis bon les échecs y at il du dopage
dans les échappements bronchait pas pas
d'hommage aux échecs c'est la tricherie
oui mais bon joueur du coup ce ne ne
doit-on pas suspendre la france bat plus
normal baril va se passer quand même le
pays qui a le tri chez jean truc le plus
grave qu'au final donc bon la ram est
bon c'est pas pour dire après c'était
mais bon juste c'est je trouve ça un peu
petit se réjouir de ce à quoi
ouais ouais je crois qu'il serait joue
quoi mais bon peu importe ça aura lieu à
l'arrêter ancien pigiste cook les
appariements sont faciles pour mam et
n'est pas au premier tour c'est facile
pour tout le monde
bah non pas pour payer un saut contre
lui quand ça c'est très dur mais c'est
pas plus simple de jeu qu'elle fonde
quelques pages non non et iakovenko
c'est plus loin la commune corinne bon
on a vu du monde max comme il en a chié
contre lui ils auraient dû être éliminés
mais après c'est un peu sa bête
oui mais je veux dire ok simek pellini
maxime match comme ça c'est juste que
c'est le podium final du bois fait il
n'a pas dominé en scène dans le petit
jeu technique pas du tout non rien alors
qu'ils étaient mieux et non mais il est
fort tu en plus moi je les aime bien
dany je le connais assez bien mais bon
faut pas on peut pas on peut pas lapin
c'est à dire des meilleurs seconds ont
du monde mais on peut pas dire que c'est
un athlète interne hors jeu c'est
marrant comme qui était champion du
monde de 8 c'est incroyable en fait
quand il pense alors à temps les partis
ont peut-être commencé mais je les ai
pas sûr
est ce que tu peux les récupérer
éventuellement ça va arriver après bon
voyage chaises longues des jeux alors
que si ça commence à 15h en fait qu'ils
ont encore mal donné les oreilles ça
c'est possible par contraire des génies
alors qu pas notre vie elles sont
parties ces partis ravasi d'ibn battuta
ils disent qu'ils aillent au bout de 4
je sortais la chronologie des matches il
a joué ou 4 à voir quoi
mais il fait ses quatre cette fois ci ah
bah oui on fout quoi si un quatrième
match de rang b quatre c4 c5 g 3g six
touchés 2 touchés soit les c3 qui
essaient 6 et 3 des 6 35 a du coup c'est
là la même quoi ouais c'est non c'est la
même il a joué aux cinq rencontres
contre trading ouais mais je crois qu'il
avait joué contre carl software 5 est
assez étonnante
ouais c'est ça la partie où il a fini un
pion dans le désert ouais j'avais fait
la vidéo avec mathieu cornette
ouais ouais mais je crois que ma matu me
mentionnait se couche mais bon on en est
là voilà les atouts peuvent déjà en
sueur en 109 les chiens mais je suis
étonné qu'ils soient pas retourner dans
la nasse dark web 1 mais c'est pas à toi
le couffo joue énormément je crois que
ça je crois ici ouais ouais bon après
vla de manille m'avait dit meilleur
choix contre maxime celle anglaise donc
topito pourra trouver non mais ya rien
de spécial à trouver mais justin ces
types de positions qui vont le plus le
gênait parce que ils ont eu à jouer b3
parce que ben y'a rien à faire de
concret et millas est très difficile
pour maxime parce qu'il sait pas tenir
la position non c'est moi son style
ouais bon b3 du coup je sais pas trop où
je
c'est un peu l'idée de bingo met à plat
de me disais quoi oued après vlad cité
par un joueur universel tu pourras
jamais être champion du monde
de son côté ben ali dans l'histoire
s'est jamais arrivé en fait je sais pas
quel point c'est jamais arrivé mais il
dit normalement ces mecs les plus
universels facile tu as été un gros trou
ça va ça va pas marcher
je vais vous dire que la maxime est il
un gros trou comme à cause de la
pression vendeuse
ouais 10 un vrai problème tu veux tu les
coupes dans la gouvernance banon mais
j'ai faim j'ai mis b3 parce que j'ai mis
des 3 mai à la chance je vais les voir
sur czech comme si moi de mon côté ça
marche
gilles may carles scène il a un gros
trou sur la drogue il est pourtant
champion du monde belge clinique est
clairement la pire ouverture possible
j'adore quand même j'ai vu il ya une
chaîne portugaise par hasard en gardant
les trucs de krikor et les mecs cd génie
absolu quoi enfin le mec il reprend le
délire de la grob portugais et du coup
il fait des séries de vidéos sur la
grotte le late a fait une vidéo un
maître international joue la grande
faille très heureux de la grotte en fait
et les médias sont déjà en fait c'est
fou quand c'est comme le délire visite à
ce que les délires va se tasser quoi en
fait tu regardes même dans d'autres
langues le délire continue quoi c'est
fait c'est dingue d'avoir lancé ce
délire sur leur faim non mais votent
cette avenue trucs des ordis ouais j'ai
vu j'ai vu la grave c'est pire que f 3
ar est largement assez bien vraiment
pire coup en fait j'en attends un ami
sûr sur half enfin il l'a 0 bon ben je
dis que c'est le pire coup de loin csx
et le pian s'il fait un tous les ordis
que c'est le pire coup bah oui mais bon
enfin parce qu'ils prennent pas en
compte l'esprit non oui pourquoi pas
l'esprit donc forcé
ils sont en difficulté h3c papier normal
je crois c'est beaucoup mieux badger
carte soit affaibli fin je pense que
passer son tour et mieux que j'ai 4
c'est bien sûr puisque les noirs ne sont
pas vraiment moins bien c'est beau j'ai
quatre fait vraiment des trous partout h
3 à 3 et c'est comme ça bon bah tu
gardes le contrôle un peu d'ailleurs
à trois ils dit pas si mauvais leur dire
non meilleur que je crois à troyes il te
dit mieux non mais tu te dis même pas
pas si mauvais du tout en fait un voeu
que les notes à 69 à des trésors en fait
chance g20 tient aussi à ce jour sur
mango 2 ou pour les coûts ouais ouais
non non il y aura rien
non mais ça va venir pour ce sont
surveillés à distance façon tatchell bon
ben ouais ouais mais c'est vrai chez
qatari la raison tu vois moi je suis je
suis le premier à le prouver quand un
joueur arrive est très fort il peut
jouer n'importe quel coup contre un
joueur plus faibles exactement
complètement complètement tu peux te
permettre de faire j'ai quatre contre un
mec un peu moins fort un petit jeune
talentueux quoi tu tu essaie de le
prendre un peu à revers tiens comme dit
cyril et joue à jouer georgeault une
grotte contre 1 contre un faible
norvégien lambda quoi ouais c'est
faisable khwaja passe par un exploit si
jc apparaître ce troll à l'époque on
était au courant c'était le pire coup
fondée par check et on se doutait on n'a
pas grand respect pour g4 en soi ouais
mais heureusement fait ça donne
confiance mais c'est de partir à
l'incroyable en fait je suis très fier
je pense est vrai après tout le long
celle ci qu'en fait tu vas de l'esprit
était avec moi je pense très importants
l'esprit qu'est ce qu'ils peuvent faire
[ __ ] en c3 maxime talbot réfléchissons
déjà à jus blanc l'a pas non enfin je
sais pas vous prendrez prend des
premières dames adam 17 puis je n'aime
pas du tout filet [ __ ] kazan non mais
des fois il aime bien faire du tour un
jeu était toujours pour eux quatre pour
b4 part
x pourtant non mais juste du blog quand
tu as une sorte de nîmes se faire avoir
le fiancé de honnêtement mais facile à
comme ça mais bon bon tout les d'apple
c'est juste que les pcistes tranquillou
et voilà si ça continue
j'aimerais bien pouvoir ajouter les noms
quelque part ben en fait le truc c'est
que je pense tellement que ça va arriver
d'ici à une minute à l'autre que je mens
je parlais le fort d'être et soir je
suis serein m et 6 6 6 à 25 essayez pas
bon j'imagine que topalov tubes et de
haies des 4 ans maintenant la gdc la
position comme ça et il faut prendre ces
trois du parlement dont il qualifie ce
jeu est floue et de jeu de high rock du
coup parce que sinon il ya eu des cinq
qui menace non tu peux faire que valeo 4
aussi marqué les quatre palettes mais
bon qui répondait à 4 je pense au tour
c'est un an juste poussé trop échangiste
cjr risque de topal chose à perdre une
troisième fois avec les blancs qu
ensemble la question se pose mais je me
demande s'il ferait pas mieux de faire
annuler en fait topalov fétiche en jeu
ouais je joue tout sur une partie je
sais pas tu peux tu mets la pression sur
une seule partie je m'assieds pas mieux
de faire ça en fait tout est mieux que
perdre la première est que les blancs
parce que c'est un peu chocs quoi ce
qu'il a à chaque fois que j'ai parlé par
deux fois que j'ai vu renvoyer rival
avec les morts il accepte aujourd'hui
coup on suit c'est que des françaises
dans les quais noirs à avoir fait naître
une sicilienne à wilshere joie 4 oui
mais c'est pas trop et il délimite vite
en sueur un fils avec cette temime l'ua
proposait d'ailleurs et la deuxième fois
ouest et la française des changes bien y
connaissez pas du tout en fait la
première fois l'équipe mais sefyu qui
dit que total était plus de 2800 estimé
que non mais bien sûr ils étaient plus
de 2000 mais est il en fin de carrière
il joue quasiment plus il est plus
motivé
c'est pour ça après intrinsèquement
c'est un très bon joueur mais c'est
comme si sainte je vous raconterai
hewitt au tennis maintenant sur wii
lancée durant un mondial très fort bah
oui mais c'est plus mauvais 8 que jan
2002 je serai bien je compte yannick
noah était en sueur niveau où il est
numéro deux mondial numéro trois mondial
tu sues kodégué roland garros mais c'est
ça donc tu aimes c'est qu'il ya qu un
seul joueur que tout par l'afld a réussi
à battre dans les grands prix cette
année
bah oui c'est le même d'ailleurs deux
fois
ouais maca mais ce n'est pas un athlète
c'est beau en fait qu'à chaque fois que
tu es 2 0 à macaq facile oui mais bon il
est retraité aussi bon a dit à des
coupes à la découpe un nom poubelles de
ça pour le moment un statu quo c'est du
coup mais je réfléchis bon je vais
devoir ok mais bon l'option ses
cavaliers ou quatre comme on disait
cependant je fasse toiture et ferme car
mania 4 plutôt bon tu laisses et changer
la boîte fait des cartes après tu fais
des 4 es tu reviens peut-être vivre vers
détroit
aucune verra si tu reviens vers ces
trois jours il est bien versé 3,3
cavaliers pour aller sur des siècles
avant postes mais je pense tu es heureux
parce que du coup tu as le bon fiant
qu'eto'o en fait avec les blancs pas le
fou enfin tu as tu eu peut-être la
réalité de faire des 3 4 des 4 tu as
parfois et au top lundi d après ça va je
suis sur un peu près pendant aussi mais
bon non mais bon ok rock cette part est
logique et est offert des quatre ses
positions je n'aime pas jouer avec les
noirs je sais que c'est rien mais tu te
sens toujours un poil moins bien en
voilà c'était pour les styles de joueurs
mais je peux comprendre le côté
inconfortable puisque une petite
pression montait avec l'élan je pense
qu'il faut toucher à rien maintenant si
s2 y ont peut-être dan 17
par exemple je sais pas pourquoi
mais bon toujours pas raison en fait je
pense pas je préférais jouer que ça
aille car elle a eu quatre dont tu ne
viens de nous parler parce que là tu
peux faire des français qu'elle valait à
quatre tableaux chiant mais je changeais
la dame par tour d un des fois tu froid
des cavaliers qui allait chez paou des
clous h sur le dernier bonal si tu fais
blessy style décalé ashtiani camionnette
a raison c'est pas mais ça me donne
l'impression que les blancs ils sont
juste un peu mieux non ouais bon après
ok je partais tient lieu 4 5 ou
peut-être que tu peux aussi jouer que
kallio 4 changé plus de casement
affaires ou 5 tu mets ta structure sont
en afrique noire
enfin à rayer des options sais pas mais
faut pas jouer je pense qu'il a raison
mexique de réfléchir c'est bien que joue
pas trop tempo parce que je veux avoir
des positions un peu désagréable non
faut pas tomber dedans ça sert mais ce
qui me gêne en rien mais je n'arrive pas
assez cruel épisode du pur isolé à moins
qu'il faille prendre le pack complet
quand tu peux prendre que le pack
complet en là c'est à dire voilà tu es
un niveau comme ça il ya une raison
particulière la baisse de niveau de
naqaba chemin entre celui qui s'est mis
à stream n en fab
oui bon en fait ben c'est pas le stream
en soi qu'il laurent moins bon c'est
juste l'indicateur le temps qui passe à
stream et il ne pense pas il ne passe
pas s'entraîner à travailler et à un
moment ça
conséquence il est moins motivé il bosse
moindre c'est un cercle vicieux
ouais mais bon je pense moi que ce
malheureux voilà encore quelques temps
intéressant il fait ses vidéos il aime
bien sa ville à ses followers
ouais mais non mes chances étaient très
heureux si heureux de tous
non mais le truc c'est une pastille
étonnant parce qu'on fait à une usure
mentale aussi de jouer haut niveau par
de jouer tout court en fait mais à haut
niveau ça se comprend peut-être avec des
sportifs dans les sports physique
prennent leur retraite lors qu'ils sont
encore en pleine possession de mes
moyens je pas voir où des mecs 26 ans ou
là au générique qui à 29 ans
mais on va dire que je crois qu'elle a
des problèmes je crois qu'elle a la
gamme des problèmes de rhumatismes ne
sais pas quoi au jeu pascal à quoi oui
non maman tu juste fin tu peux en avoir
marre en fait d'aller s'entraîner tous
les jours ça fait une dizaine d'années
que 6 à 15 ans il a été numéro un
mondial bon mais canon mais était bien
qu'ils ont toutes trois là dépasse les
2800 et l'olympique de chemin de saisie
plein de fois t'as plus rien à prouver
en fait et donc à la vente dans la
marque se lever le matin faire que ça
tant traîné comme un show étudient ou tu
peux vivre bien en confiant leur passion
en des briques sur internet des puzzles
rush en discuter avec la communauté
c'est marrant mais voilà donc ça ce que
je comprends très bien prendre mais
forcément bam été plus compétitif après
contre d'autres qui dieu on l'a tapotant
quoiqu'il holy shit chine qui
s'entraident que la faune qui crée un
terrain qui vient qui veulent gagner
chaque parti voilà qui a les dents
longues qui ont les dents longues ou
courtes mais qui sont outillés pour
manque donc maxime clarifier ce que 5
c'est aussi une option ici fable bas je
dirais - sedan qui met le plus à l'est
en sept jeux cette structure par
exercice parce que tu dis à 9,5 que dire
des options ils font un f5 du coup il y
a plutôt réussi ce donc tu as quand même
pas mal de trucs que je trouverai
blizzard avait retrouvé 6/4 et dieu sait
quoi ouais en fait quand tu joues avec
le 5
ton idée c'est soit de faire des 5
arrive à jouer un marosi avec les noirs
enfin versé du coup soit si tu fais pas
des 5 matches 5 et yamaha parkingo
s'était pas très bien passé
non mais ça aurait pu faire le dire mais
en gros si on veut illustrer la maison
vous ai dit ok on comprend ça chez vos
yeux non mais bon les gens les gens vont
sûrement la partie de ding bastia deux
jours
on parle pas d'un truc 15 ans web les
vidéos et les résumer tout ça là c'est
juste une autre chose donc on dit que la
salle n'a pas l'air confortable ouais
c'est vrai que c'est un peu embêtant que
ce soit pas super bien organisé
apparemment les grandes lignes en
général au niveau du confort pour les
joueurs je sais pas en bourse ce texte
certains sont pleins mais maxime il n'a
rien dit à ce sujet enfin dans son
article il a rien dit déjà même en privé
mariani donc je passe sur ce soit
tellement original en train d'aller
regarder un de mon côté al kanz -date
nordiques les commentaires désolé mais
non sa maxime de jeu on voit que celle
attendue l'homme ont tranché son côté
c'est assez sombre c'est les il doit
aimer les échelons l'air d'être déclaré
non mais c'est ce qu'on en fait
sa leçon mais bon c'est à venir sur
l'échiquier en fait ça même et iakovenko
donc attend ça et je voulais aussi en
profiter je vais aller choper je vais
aller choper l'article de check point
comme parce qu'on m'a demandé les
modalités de qualification et donc il ya
sami qui a écrit un article pour chaque
gare
patrick est tout pour expliquer tout est
donc
donc ouais notre bien et sinon bah le
résumé c'est quoi c'est que les grands
principes série de quatre tournois où on
marque des points suivants sa place à
l'issue de chaque grand prix donc c'est
un peu comme la formule en fait et le
but c'est à la fin efira et deux
premiers bon là où bien évidemment qu'on
se fait un truc beaucoup moins simple
que ce que j'explique c'est que les
jambes je peux trois grands prix sur les
quatre noms mais s'est refusé à être
rapide très simple c'est la fin de l'
explication mais là non ça règle est
donc possible
la légende veut que trois grands prix
sur les caps donc c'était un peu par
choix ou suivant leur calendrier donc en
fait du coup tous les grands prix n'ont
pas tout à fait le même niveau
ces amplis là y'a pas rogner les
radjabov qui qui ont décliné de jouer
ils seront remplacés par des mecs donc
moins fort que juste à vélo donc prendre
le premier grand prix à moscou est
extrêmement fort aux autres ça c'est
clair bref bon ceci étant dit les
joueurs marquent des points
wales a d'ailleurs c'est assez injuste
toujours des points voilà donc
volontairement à gré de choc qui lui a
déjà joué ses trois ans prix qui a 20
points en tout et donc maxime pour
l'instant est second avec 13 points
donc il est bien il a son destin entre
les mains mais tu as des joueurs qui l'y
ont aussi pas trop mal réussi c'est ma
vie dira fait nepomniachi ont chacun
gagné un des trois premiers grands prix
bon par contre ils ont ils ont foiré au
tournant marque 1 0 mais du coup son
tour dans la course plus des joueurs qui
ont fait les trois plus moyen mais ont
quand même marqué des points ici et là
je pense à gauche la secte et une demi
finale
sauf qu'elle fait un quart et une demie
qui donc sont un peu largués mais s'ils
font un gros tournoi en empochant des
points à fond ils ont peut-être leur mot
à dire quand même elle est tout même si
ça sera quoi bon pour le coup ils
ajoutent qu'ils allaient aux 4 maxime
gonalons a senti que c'était meilleur
cavalier 4 après une fois qu'on a un peu
analysé
voilà pourquoi tu évites d4 et voit donc
pour en finir voilà donc en gros maxime
pour l'instant c'est mieux placé il a
son destin entre les mains mais barré
les faire et donc c'est important qu'il
fasse un bon parcours et au cas où ça se
passe pas de pour lui il faudra prier
pour que les joueurs les plus produits
au classement rapporte on demande son
prénom qui je trouve quand même
hallucinant déjà joué que trois tournois
sur quatre et cumuler les points des
quatre tournois bah en fait tu joues que
trois tournois donc tu cumules pas
vraiment fait sa gloire cumule les
points des trois tournois
oui peut-être chacun jeune ou trop
tournant on a pas que l'on joué quatre
comme d'autres font trois non mais c'est
bizarre
du coup tu as 21 joueurs plus un 22e qui
joue juste un tournant une nouvelle
carte pour jérusalem est ce qu'on s'est
également fait donc face raté plus
simple de prendre que 16 joueurs à les
déjouer tous eu tout le temps ça calgary
- là dessus par été trop facile ça
aurait été trop facile à expliquer au
public s'arrêter trois temps comment est
ce que je peux rajouter les noms je peux
mettre un truc à la main de diego baisse
ouais j'ai pas trop envie de faire ça je
vais à fait ce que je vais faire je vais
faire différemment on va on va perdre
échiquier pendant une seconde aux îles
mariannes à bout ce qui se passe sur les
autres
les autres partis genre mal mais yacou
n'est plus au golf en fait aucune autre
ascenseur et voilà ok moi je sais c'est
que breaking peuvent être les futurs
adversaires de max tu peux tu peux me
donner des coups et éventuellement
depuis le bus way c4 c5
j'ai projet si ce projet de fou g7 kelly
c3 belliciste is they believe trois des
six rock fort simple mais trois
cavaliers psy ce four b2 qui a eu lieu
car il vient de jouer cavalier à 4 rires
et fous prend b2 qu'elle prend b2 alors
qu'un bon comme ça comme ça on a fait
comme ça on a récupéré fab les noms des
joueurs en dessous
pierre atteint il c'est pour mettre plus
de joueurs c'est la raison ouais enfin
bay à la bombe un bref séjour les mêmes
problèmes qua non mais pourquoi pas son
joueur alors conduire pour qu'on
s'arrête à 21 un moment où il y avait 16
et masseuses j'ai besoin de voir passer
à 32 sur bus c'est un peu plus votre
mouton sont 85
tu fais ce que tu veux mais tu es juste
un truc normal évitables comme tout le
monde mais attention
les bottes la prochaine fois je m'en
fous rires candidat françois un système
beaucoup plus compliqué vrai six
tournois des candidats à chacun anjou 4
1 mais vlad pour les grand prix féminin
il est très très énervé d'un truc alors
là mais vraiment très très énervé en
fait c'est un truc de fou avec les grand
prix féminin c'est que les filles qui
sont déjà qualifiés aux candidats ont
officiellement depuis le début nous ont
quand même le droit de jouer les grands
prix alors déjà bannie comprends pas oui
bon ok
et en plus elles prennent les points
normal ce niveau ok mais justement si
elle jouait la fin juste après les
primaires prennent pas les points quoi
balade non en fait elles prennent quand
même les points pour se qualifier si
jamais mais si jamais quoi ce sont
jacques agid nom met donc en fait les
frais du coup ce sera ce sera les
joueuses après qui seront qualifiés mais
vlad et est dégoûté parce que cannes et
f4 a fini 3e au premier grand prix
derrière jouer june & gallet guerrier
qui n'a quand même n'est donc voici les
premières des non qualifiés
oui mais elle prend les points de la
troisième place mais en fait ils juste y
comprend pas le système fassi tu fais un
tournoi qualificatif pour quelque chose
quelle est la logique d'inviter des
joueurs qui sont déjà qualifiés en fait
bonjour ça non mais v'là de salles mais
en pls ce total il dit mais c'est fin
qui fait les réclament je fais quoi moi
même fait c'est c'est du grand n'importe
quoi c'est c'est idiot c'est comme
laisser carlos années 40 à nos fans
aussi oui oui c'est le même style est
bondée poids déjà fait nul avec les
blancs attention oui mais au moins pour
nike pour line of men ou moins le
résultat de caruana n'est pas content et
enfin là c'est comme si will première à
wang hao wang a fini premier mais pas de
chance ces 46 qualifie quoi salle jean
dame 17 route et tu nous as dit donc nul
chez dépôt voilà déjà dix coups bon moi
je pense au dépôt il a fait une croix
sur le tournoi et veut jouer son match
contre entre autres merveilles singo ben
tu penses bah quoi d'autre as tu penses
qu'il se dit que c'est plus facile de
battre à l'excès hancock d'aller loin
dans ce tournoi donc qu'ils préfèrent
jouer tranquille en rapide hyper hyper
et il va vous à l'excès yen comme un an
après un rapide mais pas les blancs
enfin devant dix coups ou bien moins que
ce malade qui n'a raison je peux pas
expliquer incessants c'est très
important pour lui tu as des blancs
google fronde des seuils et au pire tu
as rien de plus faux nul entre en poupe
en dise dominant c'est incroyable non
mais ça va tu as raison c'est là qu'il
doit dire jouant rapide
si je passe en rapide 1 2 tours bon bah
après si je joue un match genre en demi
et qu' il ça me qualifie je joue à fond
mais mais je vais je vais tranquille
enfin je vous tranquille en rapide non
mais bon cette attitude qu'ils soient
éliminés quoi ces traits plus haute
lande peuvent te dis je dire je bon je
peux comprendre s'il est vraiment malade
ou quoi on s'assoit me plier le dira pas
mais un an par son vrai nom ça a c'est
assez étonnant fab
cette attitude du joueur russe est-ce
qu'il va recevoir un appel du président
de la russie
non mais sinon tout juste vraiment
énervé contre les grands prix cette
frappe un scandale à à doha à hambourg
ouais parce que l'organisation est
déplorable et c'était que lâcher un peu
sur twitter après la mecque unis désolé
brouille ou non mais c'est pas mon frère
mon frère tu commences de commencer déjà
par mme parler poliment
pour le coup les ordis avait pas trop
des m17 de match oui bon il ya déjà une
semi bonne nouvelle quand même fab light
in fine une balade gratuite de dépôt
c'est quand même déjà une première bonne
nouvelle côté français oui mais bon pas
déjà il n'a pas perdu le match parce
qu'il faut quand même pas souvent rapide
oui c'est bizarre tu as dit tu es dans
quel sens de la rigueur ça fait ouais
mais il prendra pas de point de bonus
est la face aux kings 4 points de plus
que max cerci prend jamais de bonus il
faut qu'ils aillent jusqu'en finale
puisque la dernière de chara points
c'est quand même fab c'est c'est quand
même un excellent de nouvelles
négociations avant même les partis là
c'est une autre avec ses programmes tv
line et polo sentais pas dans ce tournoi
c'est plus ma mais qui n'ont clairement
mais bon c'est malgré tout on peut
givrer ne pas sentir au moins le nom peu
on peut se réjouir fab de cette nouvelle
j'ai envie déjà envie de dire on peut
mettre des petits et modem vld petit jeu
c'est pas des merdes quoi dans le tchat
je passe quand même on met des trucs
dans l'aude et vlad où je sais pas je
propose qu'on est des trucs dans le
chatt là un chat qui est pas très vivant
d'ailleurs aujourd'hui mais possède
klaus a peut-être l'horaire aussi 14h30
milieu de journée mais bon il ya quand
même un événement historique vous étiez
plus sur le coup pour le match contre
carl scène qui était qui est amicale tu
vois j'ai envie de dire où vous êtes
j'ai envie de dire on ne sait pas fab
l'armée je pense que c'est l'horaire
auquel on peut décaler h4 qui bon un tri
c'est en fait pour le coup le bon coup
c'était des 4 way
alors en fait ça peut paraître étonnant
parce que tu te dis je vais prendre des
coups yake c3 et des fourchettes ont eu
deux jardins genre cai ces trois dames
d2 puis on prend des carrières et prend
des kakis et prend des quatre dames
france et 3 qui est vendu 2 voilà ou
d'apprendre quartier fois de toute façon
c'est la même
ça a marché dans tous les sens ouais ça
se trouve mais en fait ouais sur ps3 tu
fait d'allumer un malin on prend des 4 3
est important dans la dame en main et
pendez deux silos reykjavik à 400 km
temps je comprends la moyenne est très
bien placé et bon bah du coup ça c'est
bien pour les blancs et donc du coup sûr
des quatre bacs et c3 ça sert à rien
mais quoi qu'il en soit si tu prends des
quartiers qu'il prend des quatre alors
atteint excuse moi parce que je crois
qu'il y avait un bug avec le chat donc
gt gt gt perdu à l'extérieur
oui j'étais ailleurs non pas des coups
sûrs des capi et ses trois salles
donc faut le faire peut-être comprend
des 4
mais quel écran des quatre îles et
blanc' et de ce qu'ils veulent pas ils
font jouer leurs fous de cases blanches
font mieux justifier ces trois quarts
français 6 intermédiaire évidemment
important sinon tout le problème pour
chaque pièce étroite unis bafoue
processes et puis dam des docks de vin
ou de la mer un peu tard non
ouais
me landais de spaggiari ans le 4 x 2 ou
3 peu importe on voit mais ça s'est
plutôt pas trop mal roulé en fait les
mecs sont dans le chat c'est juste notre
système avec le machin qui bug avec le
double chatwell donc jouer at-il de
topalov peuvent vu ça il a fait que les
acheteurs mois a pressé ses parents de
ne pas l'avoir vu
non mais tu peux peint pas tu peux avoir
quand même liste
oui c'est une partie lente ont trouvé
une heure 30 adap rendu pour sauver
chaque très très cul entre elles pour
pour élever le débat est en fait ouais
mais bon bah là tu es une fille nasa
trouver quoi c'est génial yeux de plus
après deux coups après la sortie de la
théorie tu as déjà deux erreurs padam 17
car il y avait quatre c'est très fin
c'est pourquoi c'est normal parce que
c'est pas idiot cali h4 parce que tu
t'en prends fouet 5 qui veut pas bouger
parce qu'il ya quatre t'évite
éventuellement le plan des moeurs de fer
h 5 h 4 parce que sa réaction par ok
c'est une option
donc c'est loin d'être absurde mais il a
joué assez vite je vois qu'il a encore
une marge 25 à la pente abrupte au
palais et des quatre s'affalait le pen
d'investiguer un peu plus peut-être
maria on nous dit dans dans le tchat
c'est guillaume blanc qui peut être
soudain maxime en train d'envisager car
il ya cinq ans pour mettre ce cas mais
ok je vois un peu au sérieux je
cherchais l'idée des moments où on se
comprend oui je viens d'en prendre un
petit peu option c4 effet 3a et quatre
chanteurs qui écrivait que reto paf a
quand même réussi à faire car ayache 406
mhz et maxime ont sur quoi mais le fait
qu'il ya quatre quelques gogos
oui oui oui il a fait dérailler à 4,6
ouais donc là ils n'ont plus vraiment là
les grands moyens
maxime jouir très bon joueur je
comprends pourquoi il était champion du
monde
je sens toute sa puissance quoi oui si
oui je suis obligé contre un joueur d'un
tel niveau de réagir et les cavaliers au
centre je ne peux pas jouer sur les
ailes très compliqué alors que rob vrai
quoi ça serait tellement bout quoi
serait-ce que parce qu'il ya le super
car aller à cannes le temps maire des
cayes haïti sky et h5 quoi vient me
chercher quoi je touche les bandes jeu
rebondit dessus et on l'a dit ce qu'ils
écrivent elles en train d'imploser mais
c'est mon plan bordel il met le cahier
sur la bande parce qu'ils trouvent pas
ce qu'ils trouvent ça beau tout
simplement au le jeu de mots de globe
trotter 42 où ils trouvent ça beau là tu
aller loin wray toujours pas les coups
qui arrive je suis mûr c'est toi qui as
les couilles dunk de dix jours pense
pour que la qualif aux candidats il
faudrait un point de bonus offensif pour
chaque coup passé avec un cas la vanille
sur la bande très beau ça les nouvelles
règles de stupéfiants sueur mais il faut
que la vallée à trois quarts aile et h3
isbat à fonc bonus offensif dégage donc
pas qu'ils boycottent les noirs qui nous
dit salut cafsa l'ufab salut
topalov peu contre le contre trois les
kayaks attaoui la même chose je voudrais
qu avec les noirs en fait j'aime pas je
sais pas en fait ça mais ça me saoule
aurait déjà enfin je serai déjà très
énervé non seulement parce que j'aurais
juste les ordis 10,5 les envies h5
j'aurais jamais fait non je veux dire
c'est quoi ton esprit va dire que c'est
fantastique de faire c'est juste ça ne
pense pas que je l'aurais non plus cette
case appartient aux cavaliers ils
allaient tous libyens la case h7 du coup
tu peux avoir une idée de manoeuvre
intéressante
ce serait beau après ce faire cavalier
justice qui agissaient tg5 qui avait dit
marc dalpé attaque à chaque fois on dit
la partie dispose sur chaque point comme
intense est peut-être arrivée du coup
faut que je remette un refresh dans les
crèches
ouais peut-être que depuis mon dernier
refresh l arrivée no fake je n'ai pas
bon je rappelle mon côté moi même bateau
guéret sur jesse bond on la laisse sur
check points comme ça chez valls aussi
forcément ça c'est sûr non les gens
disent qu'ils n'ont pas non plus n'ont
peut-être faire la prière daniel reyne
way sur evene ses alliés vrai état
cavaliers moyens d'aller sur wake et
qu'il est chez vous quelque part je peux
comprendre un peu logique elithis tu
t'en vas tu peux rouge et on fout donc
tu incites les blancs à tout prendre un
simple ce qui va sûrement jouer
bon je constate un peu moins bien ce que
je peut théoriquement faire c'est ouvrir
le direct et faire un échiquier
d'analystes en fait je peux faire un
truc willis est sage et des as tu peux
mettre le chic et du direct vers sa base
et ça pendant la semaine que fils de
quoi tu
mais je sais je sais je sais je sais le
faire quand même fait de base j'étais
tellement étonné tu vois que le truc fin
mais c'est juste que saâdane est
d'habitude dans les dix minutes ça
arrive 20 minutes la ligne de mire c'est
vrai qu'on peut passer ou même au début
de la partie danse ou qu'ils ont du
retard c'est plus tard un ok il a pris
1,25 et d'apprendre en mode studio
ouais ya eu trois âges et je vais mettre
je suis en train de récupérer le truc
les raye en fait je veux c'est vite un
taux plus bas elle a peut-être raison ce
que les dérapages non c'est pas con
honda sont trois très logique tu mets
des pions sur kaz maron vous hors caisse
blanche tu veut peut-être jouer des
quatre un jour tu gardes tes options
c'est bien mais il a raison il a raison
topi tôt pas faux mais je suis quand
même confiant ça le truc donné paula à
la nuit de n'est pas là ça m'a
complètement mis en confiance que
j'avais peur d'une demi finale tu vois
ton très beau ouais mais je le vois pas
les en double je pense ce sera chaud en
2010 et que c'est pas ce que sow sarr et
aux derniers espoirs personnes parlent
de lui mais quand je dis petit la 4.6
yens tous ses matches et peut
potentiellement se qualifier donc j'ai
mis une petite échiquier envers pas du
coup c'est pas mal or cet échiquier bien
joué et femmes tac
du coup il ya eu cavaliers situe à celle
où j'aurais joué mais sans fin j'aurais
joué ça en sachant que je suis en train
de faire le coup en fait tu vois de ne
pas jouer on met ça va c'est un peu
soupçonnant rock et surtout maxime aussi
carbure ça joue vite un voyage rock jazz
bombes des tests
work tout va mais oui c'est sûr que les
blancs sont pas mal mais là avec les
manches pour faire un peu tout ce que tu
veux
d'aveux de cavalli ac à detroit j'ai
tous les coups sont jeunes proposent de
cfk relais c'est très souple
bref tu perds tu me donnes tu peux le
faire plus tard mais mais je pense c'est
logique enfin jour une stratégie
d'émission sur casse ma cavalière à
quatre essais 3 le plein de talent et de
thaler il ya aussi très logique un bain
b2 je trouve un peu triste je sais pas
trop ce qui va devenir h3 ou s'ils
proposent leur dit à la cour qu'ils
proposent
je crois que j'aurais même aimé jouer ou
non m que de jouer un jour s'il en a
besoin mais l'a pour l'instant c'est un
peu tôt j'aurais pas fait mais je dis
juste qu'il propose moi je n'aurais pas
fait j'aurais fait cavalier à quatre
cavaliers ici puisque j'aime pas avoir
une caisse comme ça houda me de
peut-être mesdames dame c2 qui s'est
élevé à 4 je trouve ça bien
paris ce que maxime il peut le toucher
un peu variable cela peut arriver
tu as parlé bête oui bon les deux sets
mais je dois même si j'étais un truc
comme dalmat deux vainqueurs que j'ai au
pire j'arrive à tour et ouais voilà
puis bon géo car ce qui peut arriver
pour minimes cavalli enfin il n'est pas
stable quoi ouais t'as raison
battus c'est la technique je vois un
trou j'y rentre mais en fait donc leur
sens où ça fait mal un trou au polonais
est peut-être car il est à 4 et ces
trois noms mais a fait faire attention
parce que ça avec les blancs il peut
déployer leur jeu petit à petit c'est
une potion à ressorts dire est qu'il ya
quatre cahiers c3 tu m'as d'un le 2ème
en d3 tu fais fi 4h 3g 4 et plus rapide
espace je crois j'ai quatre f4 jeu
pendant que lors d'autres f4 d'abord
copains d'avant ce serait un truc comme
ça il fait un peu de dégoût lambda pour
les noir et en fait là par là on a vu
quelques coups et climat on voit qu'avec
aidant on n'a pas trop d'idées non mais
tu fait d'aveux deux des trois jeux 3 et
4 du coût est question au centre en me
casse toi qui avais liens web ont signé
des voyageurs après qui n'était pas
gagné pour autant
mais au moins tu n'y vas pas compatible
avec les morts retrouvés mais le truc
est morte a pas forcément hyper envie de
trouver voir la position où je donne tu
préfères tour ses huit baies six
histoires de mais bon je sais pas si je
sais pas en fait je n'ai pas d'idée de
points on est pour le moins on nous
demande si j'ai quatre si jamais une d4
ici jamais une bonne idée si ça peut
être un plan on est bien qu'il ya quatre
pieds ces trois jeux avec des cats mais
juste à peut-être plus envie de de
garder les pions pour empêcher aux
cavaliers de jouer puis faire f4 h3g 4
être même j'ai cinq cavaliers des cinq
un jour et après peut-être même faire
des trous 4 mai et à peut-être plus
envie de comment dire avec les blancs
pas vu que les noirs ont pas trop de
rupture comme l'expliqué fab des 5 tu
vas enfin avec le cavalier en c3 surtout
c'est quasi jamais possible puis ça à
faire jouer le fou et quoi d'autre et en
fait le problème c'est que si vous
faites des quatre aussi j'ai
l'impression qu'ils peuvent échanger et
jouent des 5
après ça les lions de detroit bah oui
c'est aux 15,3 déjà c'est autre chose
mais si on fait des quatre lundi annonce
des quatre là donc vous bouffent des 5
et en fait on se fixe une se blesse sur
des quatre cases noires dur à défendre
ils vont soit fait retour des 8es
changeant ses quatre sont désolés est ce
un problème mais repasse m'a souvent
dire un truc dans cette position là avec
ce conflit la d4 d5 est influencée 4
c'était très heureux d'avoir un cavalier
en c3 ou ans et 6 1 et jean s'il y en a
un qui l'a et l'autre qui la passe est
souvent bon signe pour celui qui l'a 6a
pas de puissance et c'est évidemment
aussi influencé cette c'est encore une
autre histoire mais sanctions ans et 7
mois souvent dit que lecavalier il était
très bien placé en c6 et l'autre en c3
du coup pour attaquer des cinq qui est
du coup un peu faible et là pour le coup
à des caps trop tôt faute des quatre à
gagner dans ces 3
de notre histoire mais quoi qu'il en
soit aussi une autre manière de réagir
actes et noir que le pays soit n'importe
où on sait 3,7 faire beau il ya
maintenant cette fois il fait des quatre
cdd c'est aussi de jouer avec le 5 est
clair et de sauter sur des cartes avec
lecavalier
je suis pas sûr que les gens soient
vraiment ravi quoi parle d'un cavalier
c'est bien quand c'est un socle et un
appui stable une position est donc temps
que les blancs tiennent en respect car
des pions des pas trop aux écoutes
adapté sous les galets noirs sont pas
trop fort un cavalier blanc ils ont plus
intérêt à faire le plan qu'on a dit on
va perdre et pour un peu ridicule pour
les noirs pour bien montrer chaque mois
sur les pièces 3-4 en fait avec les
noirs tu as du mal à en fin vraiment à
empêcher cette position c'est dur je
sais même pas quel coût inutile on
aurait pu avec les noirs nés du coup
clément prête à toutes les options
photos lettres mais bon allez droit soit
peut-être des a3b 4 ça peut arriver
f5 20 tu vois même g5
bien sûr j'ai 19 ans je suis pas si tu
l'as dit j'ai 5 g pas comme disait le
chat en même temps oui mais donc bons
pour faire
voilà ça c'est l'idée des blancs alors
yaghoub inside donc qui écrit les
articles pour pourchasse comme qui nous
écrit dans chat hello qui est fabriqué
ces standards cette idée qu'avait le
cadre de maxime d'échanger les fous de
cases noires intuitivement ça semble
suspect je suis passé standard
propositions assez rare mais profiter de
la grande diagonale pourquoi pas après
le truc c'est que grâce à son jeu et
l'embauché ou blanches jouaient des
quatre à nous ce que j'ai versé de
mémoire des quatre de base
ouais parce qu'en fait si tu rembobine
un peu au 6e coup juste pour dire aux
gens wen décisisons rock et l'allier le
6 il a joué 5 1 contre digue
ouais mais donc surfer kireev 6les blanc
veut faire des caf bouffe cavalli prend
et du wushu 17,3 bon c'est un type de
position c'est pas un peu bon moi je
trouve ca global pour les blancs est un
peu plus d espace met à patrice avec les
noirs que faire
ces huit d'expérience ça va ça celui de
faire des plaques damas cinq dames h5
sajoo mais en fait en gros dans la
partie une fois que je vais [ __ ] 5 et
que les bleus ont fait b3 qui souffre et
de fait si tu rock et que tu espères des
quatre tasses juste nouvelle version de
sang en fait tu sais j'aurais fait un
truc fab pour cette position là j'aurais
juste comparer pièce par pièce
j'aime bien celle là tu fais un truc de
corée toi ouais corner tout aussi vrai
les deux font ça en fait tu compares
fait surtout les fous pas je trouve que
le fait d'avoir floué de fouché s'est tu
peux matt égalité même s'il faut faire
légèrement le fou g7 parce qu'il est
protégé mais en revanche fou j'ai deux
foulées f5 ça fait mal hein ouais bon
125 monde et se séparent mais la façon
tu dois jouer comme soudée sait tout
faire qui les prend dé 4,2 me prends des
notes ça je comprends mais youssef ou 17
serre que fera philosophiquement tu as
perdu un tempo donc ça risque mais je
sens que je vais dire et si tu laisses
le fond f5 baffe tuchan qui fait rien en
fait 80 ans appartient plus à 17 kiev 5
on va boucher déjà aucun problème oui
bon après tu peux faire ça ça mais là ce
truc on parlait pièce c'est juste à
écrasant que les blancs sont mieux bah
en fait le truc qui fixe équivalent et
aux quatre bons keflavik est pas aidé à
me ranger c'est tout je crois qu'il ya
pas d'aveu 3 tu bouges tout et ça c'est
toujours mieux que taratata bien tu as
bien donner la bonne variante enfin on
voit bien que le fou g2 est supérieur au
fouet f5 parce que notamment un alors
juste avec la structure de pions là ça
laisse des trous là ça vise rien lui il
y là les pions sur noir enfin il est
bien quoi il est le deuxième problème
c'est que dans ce genre trouvé bon lait
blanc peut jouer bêtement mettre les
tours sur la colonne des et regarder les
percées ses 5 4 5 + l'attaquent
directement h 4 h 5
tu peux créer des problèmes une tour en
d4 peut coulisser et les normands pas
genre plan est en souffrance avec les
nancéens super aguri mériel voit la
structure à deux les taux de maroci sa
femme donc en gros tu veux pas les noirs
entraînement donc dans votre histoire
cabello 4 c'est un peu pour éviter tout
scénario scénarii
ce n'est qu'en deux jours on s'est
toujours quoi voilà parti l'a bien jouer
cavalier à 4 comme on l'avait prévu et
maxime qui a joué tour à des huit donc
là aussi comme on l'avait prévu en fait
ouais bah écoute c'est d'écologique
mais je veux dire que sûrement les
blancs doivent être mieux
étonnant quand même de se refaire
prendre sur ces quatre voilà pas surtout
qu'avec les membres de la sortie des
coûts des oufs bon c'est pas il n'y a
pas mort d'homme pour son abolition
mais on dit que le redis profondeur 65
cas comme il le faut ni ça après b3
proposé de jouer 5 charmant problème
qu'avait lieu cette rock et faut ici
c'est quand même ce qui était logique on
en a parlé mais juste software 5 g 20 il
est très bizarre pour zurich souffle
enfin l'ordre ni trouver une
justification musulmans ça je comprends
et je tape envie peut-être il se dit fab
com
en gros tu retombes un parti qu'on me
ding sauvetage ou de faire simple en
france 65 c'est que ce soit arrivé
merci sa part les noms mais le cinq de
base un bon set up mais avec 25 c'est
très étonnant parce que tu as pu le
blanc dessins ou des la salle est ce que
tu as mal milf ou tu t'en remets le
point à 4,5
donc tu viendrais à 20 ans tu est obligé
de perdre oui mais bon pas du coup dale
moss apte à jouer six coups au palmarès
j'ai pas bien tu en brionnais mathieu
zahedi c'est une pulsion tuer le temps
tu attends tu parles on attend juste
moins bien imagine kelly c3 ou d'aveux
deux dames 2 c'est pas bête évite de se
prendre la tête à trop quelques mac ice
étroite à quoi calculé rien mais en fait
tant de temps à 400 pages et des
tramways c'est ça saoule menaçant ses
trois tours la pêche aussi sont dans le
dos de cheval genou oui donc dtc3
ferment tu veux mais je pense était plus
sur le damier de cook et ses 300 %
non c'est vrai qu'un quart eli si bien
place en a quatre c'est un petit peu un
crève coeur de bah oui juste en train de
marquer des points bonus indécents
alors je comprends je comprends à tanger
c'est de rouvrir le chat ici parce que
c'est pas évident de contrôler le chat
sur un autre écran de jets de checker
mahmoud un nom va je les mets juste
c'est mieux si c'est tout sur le même
écran on est plus tranquille
non merci on va voir si discret ouvre
faucheux québec a pour provoquer à 3 et
ensuite pouvoir jouer cavalier à 5
on sent quand même un club d'experts
contre le café ak steel dans les meneurs
les cadets à la bande et c'est vrai que
lecavalier en plus il enfin il est venu
là il est parti ici il est venu là il
est revenu et c'est quand même beau s'il
revient en c3 et si revenez plus tard
dans la partie de nouveau à 4 ans fait
ses gammes un cavalier de qualité
et la partie mam et iakovenko et ce qu
elles s'ouvrent bien aurait nickel tu
vois je peux je peux pas bouger les
pièces mais je peux passer tu vois ça
c'est ma mediaco ce qu'il en est ouais
je peux et je peux rembobinez toi je
peux je peux faire des trucs 1 quand
même là si tu veux là je suis à wemmel
donc c'était une idole
oui ok moi j'aime bien les blancs
visuellement mais sait jamais si grave
ce histoire que le moteur je me dis que
psion des puzzles meilleurs jamais car
sans arriver à gérer cela en valait away
je pense à priori c'est quand même le
jour à travailler mais comme le rival le
plus proche et vu le tableau tournant à
vue même tu as faim lui qui est pas nue
en dix coupes
ce qui frappe surtout c'est réussir des
chats passe et hop à la fin j'étais dire
avant de regarder ma mais non mais nous
lorsqu'enfin jusqu'au bout a dit ans
maxime lui doit ce confort et que sur
son jeu il a son destin entre les mains
quelque part ça dépend de lui comme ses
matches avec des bonus
bon mais il est très bon donc
barral incisif préfère les noirs dans
quelle bonne image de maxime jean ou non
on espère que ça en est où la pendule il
reste beaucoup de temps pour les deux là
je pense quand la partie de maxime dans
cette partie là ça est assez anecdotique
les joueurs encore plus d'une heure et
la position si ça ne l'est pas
c'est une pollution il ya quand même
beaucoup de coûts qui vont jouer sans
grande réflexion non bon ton papa trois
déjà sûre il n'a pas attendu qu'à calais
b 4 il provoque le cavalier à 5
attention à toi ça me paraît un peu non
bon ça va je crois qu'il veut il veut
créer un meilleur fait gaffe je te
pousser des 4ème et du chrtr may well as
me de tubes dans mes tableaux de le
faire quand il veut te rend bien et ce
sera la même chose tu apprends plus je
pense que oui plus que milan ne vais pas
critiquer à 3 particulièrement tu veux
pas critiquer bon c'est pas le coup
j'aurais joué à première vue on entend
toujours les ltte palop déjà et 2 2
c'est un coup à se ré table donc de
toutes façons on connaît topalov il va
être à plus un café au 35e bajus tension
c'est pour ça qu'il a décidé de jouer
plus vite
je le redis veut absolument jeu communes
dans le chatt h 5 kg 5 mai sa maxime il
va pas le faire justin wilson c'est fou
c'est ridiculement bas je n'aime pas
trop ça mais maxime va jamais faire ça
c'est impossible de jouer il faut
cornily h 5 h 3 10 ans et j'ai cinq ans
en fonction des spéciales je crois pas
ce que tu veux faire
[Musique]
si évoqué je comprends ce que tu veux
faire quand il veut faire j'ai quatre et
sur h41 peut venir s'engouffrer avec
d'ucayali au sein des trucs comme ça
ouais mais bon tu fais jamais tu fais
jamais ça parce que c'est très con sus
plage aurait déjà peur de f4 ben oui
j'adore cette idée de faire j'ai quand
même aimé mon nom ça se sera pas jouée
femmes
je pense que je pense même pas que ce
soit fondamentalement bon hein
d'ailleurs parce que l'ordi raison d'eux
c'est trop ordinateur et j'y crois pas
non mais tu sais pas combien c'est ainsi
qu'ils voulaient jacques h5 il avec
laurent 8 pas plus de sens au jeu comme
ça maintenant
mais je vois pas trop ce qui va faire
ben on voit pas alors c'est pas trop le
candidat parce que parfois c'est pas
facile d'attendre juste de rien faire
parce que peut-être le mieux c'est enfin
vraiment peut-être que roy je suis 3g 8
sais pas si idiot fin je suis un peu
caricatural 1 mais parfois c'est pas si
idiot en fait de rien faire c'est dur
parce que tu as d'ailleurs on n'a vu
personne qui a gagné comme ça contre
henry oui d'après la partie des trois
pouces et deux fous des 3c 2,4 des deux
fois trois foulées deux phocéens ya un
moment où il a voulu faire un truc la
pousser au centre perdu un pion de
logements peu partout
est ce que tu penses que maxime peut
garder des prépas pour les candidats non
c'est pas le moment
candidat tu penses
ça non mais qu on rentre chez toi tu
sens à peu près pas mais ici non non ici
peut pas la garde ok après tout si tout
le monde perd au premier tour écueil
qualifié où il peut cacher si tu as plus
de mam et plus de sauts plus de une
époque personnes étaient déjà qualifiés
après un tour bon tu peux être détendu
et à la tactique c'est bête comme idée
je vais tout garder pour les candidats
main je suis pas qualifié non mais je
demande parce que c'est une question
qu'on peut se poser
bah je me la suis posée je suis allé
poser on ne sait pas qui on le sait que
c'est à part des cas surtout en france
où est-ce que vous économisez pour le
tour de france 2000 22 ans
oui c'est non mais c'est le même genre
truc con matin
et là tu vas faire ça à kindu le matin
coût est bon pas tout mais je pense
qu'il ya que mam et sow
et peut-être vache tu as également joué
le tournoi quoi je pense c'est qu'il
croit pas trop où me va jouer parce qu
on sait jamais carette abri fischer ii
et d'autres personnes qui pensent qu'il
faut garder les prépas pour son match
contre magnus ans en novembre prochain
c'est un message à une cheville contre
magnus je garde les prêts bat pour la
défense du titre quoi c'est pas dans
deux ans à auxerre très dangereux à mes
heures qu'il a vraiment rien contre ces
quatre avec les noirs par contre ça un
peu la mauvaise nouvelle ouais je sais
pas non mais fatalement navy qui compte
jouer c'est votre vie nick inversée oui
parce qu'il est censé jouer à fait ok je
sais pas s'il va garder longtemps
ces essentiels sont à re numéro un
l'expérience compte ding était mauvaise
ils haïssent et être sans plus sentie
pas trop en avant la position
ils ont pas eu le temps de réparer 102
jours et la recto-colite tout ça donc je
vous plan b 2 1 oui topalov qui a été
malin du coup web a fait fin oui haidara
côté un truc qu'ils y tient des trous il
n'en sait trop rien militante
ça paraissait logique je veux dire c'est
ce qu'ils font tous en ce moment contre
maxime way a en outre posé une question
là dans le chat par rapport à l'epo qui
a fait nul rapide donc on a un petit peu
parlé tout à l'heure sur le live fab fab
souligné le fait que les pauvres
probablement tout jouer sur son match
pour la wild card contre alex et and co
mais après c'est pas pour autant qu'il a
le temps d'en abaisser de gagnants
rapide
je trouve ça juste étonnante patenté
avec les blancs du coup je veux dire il
n'ya même pas non mais c'est bizarre de
faire du landy couvrir donc évidente que
ce que ce qui va se passer avec les
sportifs russes avec cette histoire de
dopage va écoute c'est vrai que pour les
candidats est ce qu'ils vont du pouvoir
avoir le drapeau russe représentait la
russie fin tu as et je sais pas trop
comment ça se passait j'ai un peu
regardé le mur de sud offs qui savait
pas non plus remettre normalement tu te
présentes pas mal de monde et notre
position qui est que tu es le drapeau
russe ou paquet chouki astra rustin rien
c'est juste du débat qui se change qui
joue qu'un drapeau russe connaître son
nom sur la table mais en fait pour eux
ça change fab mais pour qui mara pour
great yuke baie de bombay en fait non
mais il est russe est prête il peut dire
ce qu'il veut à chaque fois pour eux
c'est important en fait c'est pour eux
c'est important
c'est sûr en fait pour les russes c'est
sûr que c'est important c'est pas la
même culture c'est pas la même il a
ajouté me faille ils vont trouver ça
très humiliant par rapport à leur pays
et à leur nation
oui mais ça peut juste les motiver aussi
un oui mais ça peut me oui bah oui oui
madame je sais pas dans quel sens ça
valait aussi j seront dégoûtés un ancien
mais la faune au contraire ça va les
énerve à fond globalement tu vois la fin
mais en fait je ne vois même pas pas
donc ça me change un médecin tout
symptôme individuelle et si tu sion trop
t'empêche de jeu olympien doit tout par
équipe ça c'est une autre histoire
pendant individuel c'est individuel
empêchera pas que tu restes heureux que
tu aies le drapeau bonne entame et
partie
salle et ça ça va ils vont pas être
enfin vraiment ils vont pas être heureux
il serait il serait pas heureux de ne
pas la voir vraiment il s'intéressa
comme une humiliation ou comme mais
après ce que ce qu'on est touché puisque
handicap un sport olympique non plus
mais je crois qu'on est quand même
touché bizarrement parce que c'est comme
ça qu'une grande compétition les jeux
mais en fait c'est sur toutes les
compétitions sportives
parce que je veux dire jarre c'est une
équipe russe le kit juin 8e de finale de
l'uefa ou de chez pas quoi mais pour
cette année ça change rien et ils ont
annoncé aussi que pour la finale de la
ligue des champions 2021 et 2022 elle
serait pas j'en ai une came vous en
russie elles seraient pas changé mais
voilà que ce soit je veux spécialisation
et trouvait que j'avais du coup ci pour
les universiades 2023 uche est plus qu
alan elle pourrait être annulée du coup
il pourrait chercher parce que là c'est
d'entre elles ont tenté de vendre des
trucs qui se passent en 2020 été pris de
court tout a changé à deux mois de
l'échéance
non non ils n'ont pas changé par contre
pour les drapeaux ça c'est ça c'est
possible que tu doives tu que tu dois
jouer sous un drapeau international pas
comment ils appellent ça donc pour les
bons pour l'exemple noir ou blanc mais
pour les pour les jets un peu lui le mur
dessus top 6 et du coup ils savent
vraiment pas pour les candidats ce qui
va se passer ils savent que ça n'a pas
changé d'endroit où quoi parce que c'est
trop proche mais mais ils savent pas si
dans les compétitions individuelles ils
vont ça va avoir un impact ou pas et si
ça va un impact pour les échecs
wen à l'athlète ne trois exactement donc
avoir réussi si gagne des compétitions
il n'y aura pas l'hymne national russe
qui sera qui sera jouée à vue vont
peut-être mettre le drapeau de la fille
de je sais pas je sais pas s'ils vont
aussi je vois là j'en sais rien mais
c'est juste pour dire que les candidats
ma vie c'est confirmé je pense qu'ils
vont mettre un drapeau de la foule ce
qui mettait aux bulgares à l'époque où
il avait tout fait pour que tu fais des
chansons en bulgare
j'ai par huit ensembles
ça fait une ode aux navires dont les
voix
ouais je sais pas où ils en sont ouais
franchement moi je sais pas trop si on a
renoncé et les en soit en soit ça
m'intéresse pas spécialement non plus
apprécié c'est un impact direct faut
quand même faut quand même se tenir au
courant mais en soi soit bon gros points
sont des gens dans son nom mais bon j'ai
enfin si ce qu'on sait c'est que les
candidats auront lieu ça on le sait et
ils seront bien les cas terrain pour que
ça ces choses qu'on sait et pour les
olympiades je crois pareil y'a pas de
les olympiades qui seront ses ans l'été
prochain du coup oui en 2020 elle était
2020 elles seront bien à à moscou ça ça
passe a pas changé on avait d'autres
début août minutes
ouais je sais pas elles doivent être
quelque part oui date mais je crois que
sans l'autre car elle s'adresse en août
dernier qu on apprenait que le joueur
russe trilogie c'est l'intégrisme on
dirait que je sois russe ou n'importe
quel pays bah non c'est vrai nom gc.ca
les cas déjà que des prix d'été paru
sans fatigue je crois que ce serait plus
dans le viseur que d'autres ouais non
non clairement que leurs balais bulgare
c'est pour ça donc ils ont été suspendus
d'ailleurs chiffre peut-être je sais pas
pourquoi c'est un problème c'est ton
papier cotisation si on apprenait une
telle triche organisée dans des équipes
nationales c'est clair que ce serait
très grave
art à mios mai
[Musique]
mais bon ça n'a pas été le cas après le
sujet sur le sport avec le truc et tout
ça c'est encore un autre problème quoi
mais bon pour les échecs mais pas
vraiment de ça ça vient aussi du fait
qu'on se prend pour un sport alors qu'on
n'en est pas vraiment un coin à nous le
dopage il est très clair de chaque
passage siblequin triche base hors du
coup bref bon pour revenir un parti
c'est chaud là d'ailleurs c'est du
réseau mais bon max passe un peu son
tour wi max qui passe un peu son tour et
on nous proposait dans le chat un plan
des trois dames des dames des deux dames
b2 pour jouer des quatre qui me paraît
pas idiot d'ailleurs le nom mais en fait
je pense qu'avec les bains ont pas se
presser pour renforcer à fond la
position veut plein de coups préparatifs
des trois sont en vie place aussi bien
adam malysz et les tours en f1 les
années au centre sans vivres du jeu kéfi
capulet ce bien est un point fort
peut-être tu fais h3 pas tu tu as
tellement de temps de préparer qu'il
faut le faire oui maintenant tu as le
temps tu as le temps ont bâti ce matin
qu'il ya du dopage dans l'espoir de
réflexion pas combat qu'on sache ya main
mais j'imagine que tu perds des produits
pour rester le plus calme plus
concentrés plus si plus simple mais le
gain avait tellement marginal par
rapport à ce que tu peux faire un
tricheur directement et claudine finir
si on te dit une fois l'évaluation pour
la partie c'est déjà beaucoup plus
important qu'on avoir d'autres produits
qui prendra donc une lutte très clair à
faire déjà et après évidemment n'importe
quelle chose qui va donner un avantage
par rapport à d'autres doit être prohibé
ok on est d'accord mais bon en fait
l'exemple c'est simple c'est comme si je
sais pas combien
si moi je vais faire le tour de france
j'ai beau me charger comme je veux je
vais pas gagner balles de match mais
perd gagne ou pas par contre tu prends
jeu par andy schleck lui fait venir
jouer un match contre carlson sauf que
lui tu lui file le programme des chèques
mais il va juste gagner 2-0 quoi mais tu
vois la science montre bien que c'est
pas jouer aux échecs sera champion du
monde
alors que c'est par nos banques tu as tu
veux tu être le meilleur dans un sport
juste à niveau égal ça te donne un
avantage
donc voilà la deuxième différence aussi
je trouve aux échecs c'est que si tu
triches tu le fais exprès japan ou
hasard tout est partie prenante dans la
stratégie de triche côté des complices
ou tu regardes ton ordi on téléphone
longtemps pour être comme ça a été fait
alors dans le sport en fait tu peux
juste aussi faire confiance à un médecin
qui depuis longtemps est dit tiens ce
sera bien tu vas bien récupérer avec ça
et tu en sais rien
donc en fait pour moi aux échecs c'est
pire et c'est cette histoire de triche
qui est le vrai problème vous faut
arrêter de parler de peut-être un petit
avantage de six mois c'est ça le truc
ouais après pour les pour les produits
qu'ils adorent la concentration pour
connaître des joueurs de haut niveau je
connais personne qui prend vraiment de
produits spéciaux pour les échecs c'est
pour ça que je dis est ce qu'il ya
vraiment des choses qui aident si ça a
été vraiment on sort et qu'ils en
prennent non bah oui non mais lequel je
connais des joueurs qui ont du mal à
dormir qui du coup prennent des
somnifères truc comme ça je peux appeler
ça une aide passée fut tout un de
malades considérés salute pu s'appeler
un art qu'autre chose quoi ils disent de
la d re a lâché je connais pas du tout
en fait pour se concentrer
je connais pas du tout mais j'aurais
peut-être essayer coiffe un séchage est
arrivé dopé aux arénas cette fantastique
je vais prendre deux fois plus de classe
pour sa rigueur ils prennent du calmant
ou quoi mais des amphétamines mais bon
une des seules fêtes remercie ça
augmente la performance et de 2,6 sur
les 10 premiers terminaux besikats ça tu
dois suspendu aussi mais pour moi moins
durement que si on te chope avec un
téléphone un ordi des oreillettes suis
donc tour c'est un roi g7 way maxime qui
emploie notre stratégie fab la stratégie
de je passe mon tour wait and see donc
la partie qui va bien que j'ai
tranquillement
- petit des trois qui pour ces deux
dames 1
certains cas à partir mais je pense en
fait topol pas tout intérêt à vraiment
préparé c'est un conte portable d'un
point de vue psychologique d'être là à
voir tous les plans possibles adverse
était là et toi tu fais rien pour
garneau jouer en fait lorsque rendent
directement l'argent ça doit devenir
concret du calcul soit beaucoup plus que
nous et à notre ami alcoolique unique
pour les haricots verts il ya une
tolérance à 200 grammes au dessus ça ça
devient à cette venue dopants d'accord
mais vous savez le bon dosage soit 100 g
de haricots verts pas mais c'est vrai
qu'en athlétisme les russes ils ont
déconné à youtube qu'il dit ça c'est
vrai c'est vrai que j'ai pour avoir un
pourrait être intéressé au dossier tout
ça ils ont vraiment déconné ray non mais
en fait ils ont déconné suspendu on va
les défendre
non non juste que de raison non mais
juste moi je considère que si si les
tournois d'échecs voulait plus être
organisé en russie pour une raison x ou
y je pense que ça ferait du mal aux
échecs faille
enfin je pense que pour nous en fait on
pour être des victimes collatérales de
ce truc là parce qu aux échecs ya pas eu
de problème et on pourrait soit la
victime collatérale mais c'est ce que
c'était le fond de ce que je voulais
dire en fait c'est comme l'argent pour
des choses qui sont ou qui ont des
doutes sur les gens poussent mais je
comprends pas d'où ça sort
ouais surtout qu'ils n'ont pas de
champion du monde
ils sont un peu à la traîne depuis
quelques années pas de doute à voir les
joueurs russes comme ça ne veut pas pas
plus que pour les autres non plus pas
plus pas moins ne le dira
son sous-sol où tout le monde soit
personne ça hein d'être dans ce truc de
parano tout le branchement je danse je
pense est encore très marginale
toutes les histoires qui est ennuyeux à
pourquoi pousser f4 et pas dès 14 ans
l'a expliqué tout à leur fabrique sur
des quatre on a peur art peut-être mans
sa part est une daube siècle à tours en
c1 il a d'avancé 8 mais en fait on en
gros on avait peur de cette structure de
pions ouais ça sur le dos ça donnerait
le noir la possibilité de la maxime de
de contrer de contresens a plutôt une
bonne opération pour la peine pour pour
les noirs mais les du fait que les noirs
n'ont aucun plan
on a beaucoup plus intérêts avec les
blancs à jouer des petits coups rampant
et à attendre et à préparer quelque
chose et voir après si c'est à base de
baies 4 à base de f karatas 3g 4g 5
abbas peut-être même deux des quatre
plus tard où on ne sait pas a faim on
peut aussi ramener le cavalier voir
enfin on peut jouer cette position
pendant 10 15 20 25 ou avec les blancs
sans rien faire et peut-être même
attendre que l'adversaire s'envoient en
l'air
jackson jouera très bien simple car
cette soirée horrible là dedans il a
fait dame ces deux hôpitaux pas ou
neutres qu'ils remboursent un petit peu
mais le peut-être faire dame b 2 watts
eu tout faux 28 et toujours tu cherches
un de ces trois dames des jeux d'amour
cède pas ou peut-être des cas là
peut-être pu nuire tout et d'options
marc sasaki qui le côté un peu pénible
delà de la position vraiment donc
fabrice a commencé depuis combien de
temps ça a commencé à 14 heures donc ça
a commencé depuis un peu plus d'une
heure mais pour le moment la mauvaise
nouvelle c'est que c'est qu'on est un
peu moins bien position inconfortable
mais bon il n'y a pas péril en la
demeure non plus je pense que maxime va
la tenir fab honnêtement oui bon après
tout devra être bien là au moment où
nous ça va s'ouvrir
bon ça viendra plus frontale comme
affrontements mais pour l'instant n'est
pas grand chose à faire à part attendre
et pacy n'a pas s'énerver pas se faire
des trous par tron évolution douceur
prochain peut-être et b4 comme une idée
des trois f 4 en a parlé
maxime tu apparais ampleur dit qu'ils
proposent des rêves ça qu'ici on fait ça
dépend à quel point tu es obligé de
chercher du césar de tomber 12 8 me
nul ne dépend ni coup on est au courant
à propos de sirois g8 éventuellement web
non mais c'est ce qu'on ait à leur roi
je suis 3e set j'ai eu c'est peut-être
le mieux en fait avec et noir non mais
vraiment faim avant toi tu as déjà joué
des parties comme ça où tu as juste
passer son tour c'est vraiment une
humain à faire même en sachant que ça
peut être la meilleure solution
bah tu n'as pas le choix du coach mais
chercherait des chercheurs 4 un marché
un truc d'assises bessin écrire des 5
ce qu'il faut surtout pas faire même des
séries kahn de faire un truc qu'il faut
pas faire en connaissance de cause quoi
parce que trop difficile de passer son
tour ce que je pense que des rêves cinq
dames des deux dames s'est vite c'est
pas idiot en fait oui mais qu'est ce que
je vais dire non mais aussi sorte
confiance peut-être si tu penses tu as
tu l'impression qu'il arrive tuque noire
une fois mais c'est pas facile de ouidah
l'autre joins toi tu es là
europe serait génial tu regardes l'autre
joueur
genre tu le regardes vraiment quoi et
merci à un rush rush combo qui savent
hohneck twitch prime c'est son deuxième
mois d'abonnement est il écrit je ne
sais jamais si ça soutient plus là ou
sur big three mais j'adore vos com et
bonjour fab libye avec qui j'ai parlé en
corse dont quitter il te passe un petit
message merci de toute aide toute aide
pour l'abonnement pendant jeudi toute
aide tu peux tu peux tu peux te donner
ici puisque rim que tu veux tu fais ce
que tu veux en fait tout est bien en
fait tout est bien alors j'ai passé une
petite news pour la peine sur vos
abonnements de qualité mais le rythme
est une pub pour remercier jean balan
est ce que lui il n'aura pas la pub
stationnaire j'ai envie de lui dire
bravo tu ta bonne et tu n'as pas de pub
que les autres gars d'epic quoi ah oui
il doit être heureux non les autres se
tape une pub il est là il regarde un
moment très intéressant les gens parlent
de pub face est fantastique en tout cas
merci à toi moment il n'y a pas de timer
non il n'ya pas il ya un bug aujourd'hui
on fait avec les moyens du bord on s'en
sortent pas si mal finalement il a joué
h3 ya eu h 5 h loin bon c'est la
refondation des ordis un des cinq îles
on parle depuis très longtemps je suis
pas bon tu vois mal continuer par du
genre non mais la mauvaise nouvelle
c'est que c'est que topalov joue vite et
c'est vrai qu'on avait envie de le
mettre mal autant pour le faire craquer
là il va pas se fatiguer parce qu'une
fois dans la partie il est peut-être
capable de calculer correctement c'est
juste physiquement il est bien et magna
ce nom mais tout autant capable faut
dire j'ai de lui deux matches précédents
c'était quand même très chaud les
parties oui mais j'ai l'impression que
quand ça devient chaud à force en fait
ils voient le 6 mai la jeune femme
je suis plus inquiet dans une partie où
il y aura qu'un gros moments chauds
plutôt qu'une partie où il ya un moment
chose sur six sept coups qui dure qui
dure 2h 2h30 là le moment jeu il peut
être court et en plus ils peuvent
surtout fab avoir du temps jusque là il
lui reste combien je vais je vais jeter
un oeil à la bande une femme 1h15 lui
reste 1h08
ouais max 90 6 contre tout le temps oui
puis tu peux tu peux vraiment jouer des
coups à foison un bain c'est ça il peut
il peut très bien aller jusqu'au 25e 30e
en se gardant un beau 45 minutes quand
on allait réussir à lancer le débat dans
le chatt 1 les mecs monde est mort de ma
part que de base vraiment nous nous
notre base je le répète pour clore le
débat ne s'est vraiment dire que ça peut
être un mal pour les échecs de ne plus
avoir de tournée en russie parce que
c'est quand même outil un silo il ya
plus de tournois n'y ait plus long mais
ça donne oui et puis c'est quoi ça
changera stratégie pour être autre chose
ailleurs différemment non plus en plus
la russie ses gamins qu'on le veuille ou
non
ou quoi mais la russie s'est quand même
fondamentalement un pays des chèques non
ça sera toujours non mais je n'aime pas
qu'on peut ne pas le vouloir c'est
sincère sotchi a remis ça pour dire que
c'est comme si on parle de foot et le
brésil quoi oui c'est comme ça win
empiler les soviétiques ont apporté
énormément au jeu même au delà au delà
de l'organisation et tous avaient même
en terme théorique il ya un club qui
voit pas trop défendre abonnement il se
veut alors la différence entre saab et
ah bah non c'est la même chose en fait
c'est pour ça que voulait pas bien la
différence
ouais ouais non c'est la même chose donc
dame ces deux et on va faire donc
peut-être après h35 juste regarder l
écran
mon mac c'est ce que tu penses qu'ils
tentent un tour âge suite et il s'envoie
en l'air
non non non match 5 c rien de
compromettant avec ce coup tu prends de
l'espace tu veux te faire un petit h4 un
jour ça mais bon c'est sûr si tu
commences à pousser il a fait b6 brouqui
blanc mais oui c'est étiez-vous et
attendre brett et voit rien faire non il
ya que si le plan avec le g5 des indécis
fort je le vois papillon va faire sa
bombe et si ça peut sous-entendre qu'il
voulait que les cinq ou six parce qu'il
a blindé 6 1 donc peut-être aux affaires
qualifiée 3 ou dans le b2b de ré pour
empêcher des cinq mais peut-être max va
faire et que 6 des cinq du coup oui
exactement
en fait je le vois vraiment faire sans
je ne sens pas du tout cela s'ils jugent
sans cesse à quillan oui oui oui bien
sûr bien sûr bien sûr mais je ne le sens
pas en termes de tu vois de qualité de
qualité puisque tu as dante 2e civ
si des quatre est pas un coup oui c'est
déjà parce que maintenant qui a le plus
fait un choix genre l'idée par exemple
un pour montrer peut être peut-être de
jeu avec même ses cinq ici pour essayer
de créer du conflit mange pas si ça
marche un mais c'est juste moi c'est une
idée évidemment et la deuxième que tu
peux voir sur le décathlon et b4 alors
je sais pas si tu fais avec savais que
quelqu'un lui en c3 vend pas ça dur à
dire mais quoi qu'il en soit pas empêché
de ce qui se passe c'est toujours très
pénible se plonge on peut à vis du
dollar a vu faire rage et huit femmes un
mois potentiellement temps pire tant pis
par ailleurs c'est pas très rare on a
perdu de temps mais comme on le disait
ici on n'est pas un temps près avec les
gens ils te dire quasiment passé deux
tours
oui tu peux passer ton tour c'est bien
donc la mieux notée 3g guide
mais maxime non mais je sais pas sam ça
commence un petit peu à m'inquiéter là
son truc de b 6,3 g 7 h 5 j'ai
l'impression qui réussit pas à tenir en
place
ok bon v6 ça va pas vous dire c'est
juste un coup notre pensée 5 de l'option
de faire des 50 jours et voilà mais tu
sens pas comme dirait de les tendances
suicidaires n'est pas encore j'ai peur
que ce soit en train de s'approcher
femme vraiment
non mais là je suis en outre je serai
moi même pas très à l'aise au jeu qui va
faire nul avec les lorrains écoute on
l'espère on l'espère la nuit l'un veut
dire je comprends très bien la situation
enfin c'est un truc louche
ouais je conduis moi je serai pas ravi
d'avoir noah est ce que 100 expatriés
des poubelles ou alors ça peut mais pour
quoi faire problème c'est que si tu es
dame b25 par exemple on t'a donné les
cases blanches
on peut jouer avec f4 éventuellement
pour attaquer cette diagonale on peut
aussi juste jouer accueilli ces trois
pour te viser la case dessin qu'on peut
te mettre le pied en d3 et après jouer
avec des quatre oui avec des jantes a
toujours pas de rupture pas de chance
c'est sacré c'est le manque de plans
d'un monsieur sacré buzz on se retrouve
dans mentalement mauvaise le manque de
perspectives
non tu joues pour voir crif kif crocker
qui dit il a dû lâcher un max d'influx
aux grandes chasses tour maxime est ça
je suis d'accord avec toi tu tout à fait
d'accord avec iph crocker même si le
match contre ding tu te dis tu vois je
le laisse filer
sais tu vois c'est rien
ça joue pour rien ou quoi en fait une
fois que tu es devant l'échiquier tu vas
forcément jouer à fond et il a joué des
parties longues et difficiles contre
d'inga sur tous les ans l'ong
oui et quand carlson d'autant plus
d'autant plus le tie break qui a qui a
duré six heures et demie et forcément
femme tu laisses sylla se délecter plus
main dans ce genre de compétition même
si tu t'étais dit de base givet balech
tu vois non non plus si il a joué sa
chance à fond n'était même pas en dedans
lâcher de trucs là sur tulle noir et pas
dingue game il ya un fond blanc beaucoup
trop fort faut patienter boire un coup
au café complètement est lent mais suis
d'accord avec lui le mieux c'est ça mon
avis de laisser-faire dam des deux rois
g8 et attendre il a fait cas réalise ses
trois taux pas le nom mais seul bon ok
bon ça se comprend il n'est plus rien à
coeur parce que maintenant tu gagnes un
v6 de lever les yeux au qui revient en
jeu ça évite des cinq pour l'instant
donc peut-être aussi ce pour maxi veuve
selon jacques des 5 ou pour rien je sais
pas n'importe quelle frange et huit par
exemple à donner
pas facile pas facile le fab pendant pas
facile je dis non pas facile le joueur
mais je vais que les ordis j'aime bien
au 5 mai à rayssac y va doucement bien
non
cinq coupables cinq familles peut faire
mais ces taxes and être moins bien tu
acceptes d'être beaucoup moins bien
faire après le 5 trucs tu racontais gic
monté mâles 5 c'est le genre de coup
quand tu regardes quand on réalise une
partie que tu as joué tu sais que tu
regardes alors dit c'est vraiment le
genre de coups que l'ordi peut montrer
quoi quand je regarde les partis chez
moi parfois non mais en plus le problème
de l'ordi peut tenir ça bien sûr bien
sûr bien sûr il aime bien faire ça et
faire un blocus mais pour un homme c'est
dur
tu vois bien tous les trucs tu fait
partout en france à quand donc ça
travaille pas du tout est-ce que
cavalier h7 peut être envisagée ouais
mais si ce ton idée c'est de faire taire
et les g5 après roitg 2 le pion sera
bien défendu on sans compter qu'on peut
se faire sur terre et h7 peut être même
f4 qui était dans notre plan de toute
façon du tout ouais non c'est c'est une
position difficile il va falloir
attendre résister prouver qu'on existe
un finalement fable ses potes là-bas je
continue à donner un bon 60% de chance
deux nuls pour maxime
quoi qu'il en soit non mais pour
l'instant je suis pas alarmants quant à
la position en soi mais c'est le type de
parti qui va pas trop pour le style de
match et voilà diary ma calculions
particulier si tu tourne dans le vide
quoi tu attends et la deuxième chose qui
m'embête un petit peu c'est que ça peut
refaire encore une partie super longue
et comme on l'a dit maxime sort déjà
d'un tournoi assez éprouvant et s'il
faut aller chercher une demi voire une
finale pour assurer la qualif ce tournoi
peut être long et on sait que dans ses
formes à élimination directe l'influx
nerveux et ultra important non mais au
pire
disons il a aussi l'option ils ont aussi
fait nul aujourd'hui 12 et vietti nul
demain et que les blancs jaunes maltot
pas l'offre fusée est bon et rapide qui
invitera très favoris les compteurs
c'est vrai c'est vrai mais on nous dit
que ma mais bien contre iakovenko on me
dit qu'il est bien
bon ça joue quoi non mais tu as you
drive c'est moi j'aimerais pas déjà que
ça commence premier tour mme hamm et qui
a déjà pris un point de bonus et qui te
met tout de suite vraiment sous pression
directe c'est-à-dire qu'après ma mère
prend un point de bonus est éliminée
c'est fini quoi enfin tu vois oui mais
fait faut partir de principes qu'ils
votent
je sais pas consultant mandat henry
façon de votre mauvaise ça va je te dis
vont faire un gros tournoi mais je serai
dépend de moi de mes connaissances en
connaissant notre maxime nationale tu
vois le fait qu'ils puissent un peu
craqué sous pression je me dis au
premier tour pour le moment tu attends
qu'il est protégé entre guillemets il
peut pas être éliminé à la fin du
premier tour quoi qu'il en soit donc je
pense c'est quand même un peu rassurant
quelque sorte
après si l'autre prend le point de bonus
que tu le prends pas et tu sais que dans
tous les cas si l'autre se qualifie et
toi tu es éliminé c'est mort tu vas tu
être beaucoup plus sous pression tout
d'un coup donc j'aurais quand même plus
rassuré que maxime a il cherchait un
point de bonus dans ce match pour
abréger non mais tu as a way c'est que
le single je teste ses compères s'opère
mabé père elie baup air voilà c'est fini
mais prend monture non mais c'est ce
qu'on veut très clairement alors on
pourrait pourquoi pas juste un cash 4
parce que sur h4 en réalité on va jouer
g4 est pas une tour en âge suite
bon oui ça donne aucune attaque d'un
pion tout couper du reste on pioche il
ya peut être une faiblesse un jour les
blancs haut niveau quand même te faire f
4 à danser de ce côté et ceux qui ont
l'espace et donc ça va même se retourner
contre les noirs donc au final peut
faire un 5 h 4 ses pâturages 3 mais
maintenant juste le plan tombe à l'eau
merci à plone qui vient de s'abonner
avec twitch prime merci tonton jean
claude plante peut ou non et non pions
et 4 pardon je m'appelais plone woippy
ont eu quatre doubles 4 il a lâché un
set blanc mais bon il s'appelle +14 moi
j'avais vu plone parce que j'étais un
peu loin sur sur l'écran du portable
c'est loïc de points sur loïc de très
grosses régies n'a qu'à germer une puce
pour ce super g mais avec ce but avait
percuté 13h vtu véhicule à tous
monde je rigole pas tubes mais du coup
faute on a vu des gens là juste comment
est ce que plus personne ne s'abonne par
solidarité ou tout compte sa bonne en
plus vers les cubes à
bonne question j'en sais rien j'en sais
rien je pense tout le monde doit sa
bonne et on reprend le poste
mata sont henry tout le monde devrait
s'abonner surtout qu'avec twitch prime
c'est gratuit il faut le savoir mais
faut voir amazon prime falloir amazon
prime faut voir amazon prime avec amazon
prime tu as plein de choses un tat la
musique tu as la musique que moi
j'utilise beaucoup ta les films aussi
avec ça s'appelle comment s'appelle
prime prime vidéo je sais pas comment
s'appelle ta musique
tamaris biologique talent et séries tu
as les livraisons gratuites avec amazon
prime time le seul switch prime et je
crois que tu avais tu avais une remise
et a pas longtemps tu es moins 50% sur
les livres audible dont classieuse à un
moment donné en fait tu amazon prime
bientôt et les mecs vont venir te cirer
les pompes quand tu sors de chez toi tu
vois c'est toi je sais même plus comment
vivre avec ça je me soit 8 max ya plutôt
réduite
c'est à dire qui bon ce sera dit j'ai
pas grand chose non mais ce qu'on disait
de faire
pour l'instant il attend mais bon c'est
monsieur c'est très désagréable de
passer une bonne partie comme ça va
presque topalov lui va s'énerver va
envoyer du jeu rapidement ou est-ce que
tu as il va faire les calmes expérimenté
topalov homme et il va envoyer mais
c'est peut-être que tu prépares tu
compte pas envoyer plus tard mais en
fait tant que tu vois ton adversaire tu
veux jouer
roy g7 tour 8b 6 9 s'est vite tu vois
qu'il fait rien on côtoie autant bien le
laisser chercher des coups comme ça a
joué complètement
tu sais qui et qui doit être très
heureux en ce moment non alexander
reebok
il doit être assise paix pousse dans son
canap en train de regarder s'il a dû se
mettre ça sur la télé tu vois il doit
être tranquille ou avec une petite bière
sans alcool ou avec des pop corn et il
doit se dire ah tiens topaloff est en
train de me qualifier aux candidats à
tient un dépôt tu viens de faire nul moi
je pense que le seul danger pour lui
c'est maxime en finale avec les points
de bonus et mam et qui gagne donc les
doit être très heureux de la commission
de palop et loisirs est très heureuse
même si c'est vraiment le sol chinois
qui peut l'atteindre et donc tu sais
qu'il ya une magazine va jusqu'en finale
et perd mais en prenant les points de
bonus
et mam et rase tout sur son passage et
ce avec deux doubles annoncé sur un
autre qui doit être très heureux c'est
monsieur quatre chefs d'être très
content la séance on petits canapés
pareil doit regarder doit se dire oui
camaïeu 4 secoue n'appartenait pas à la
position incroyable
non mais j'ai atteint jusqu'à 1 il ya eu
quatre matins de sembler absurde parce
que tv 2d cap mais en fait je sais pas
où ça va mal tourner c'est le samedi 7
août deuxième coup dur à dire mais même
le commentateur français ne comprends
pas pas étonnant personne ne comprend
rien incroyable quoi je vais retourner
me faire un petit thé matcha
en attendant mais en fait dans le jeu je
vois que chess bombe il te dit de jouer
avec quatre autres on mettra son 5 août
dont parlait avant on sait qu en plus
d'appuis sur fête villageoise 5 passes
quand tu feras f5 vais changer 6-1 jours
il ya de nouvelles faiblesses du père de
cavaliers au dos qui a les f4 des trucs
comme ça et donc renoncer à une partie
de galère en fait est ce que ton
scénario fait c'est pas une partie qui
ressemble un petit peu au mvl radjabov
en demi finale de coupe du monde 2019
beh oui enfin je crois que des pierres
contre un job ouais mais ça ressemble
quand même un petit peu quand même un
petit peu n'en voudra
oui mais enfin l'usm et femmes
c'est un peu comme quand tu rates ton
ouverture des fois tu vas etre trés trés
mal des fois tu vas être un peu moins
bien mais géré c'est un peu ce même
scénario dans le sens où tu as
l'impression que l'adversaire a rien
fait pour obtenir un vrai avantage mais
parfois tu es plus tu as plus de
réussite et c'est pas si grave des fois
c'est très grave mais ça ressemble un
peu enfin pour moi dans l'esprit ça
ressemble un peu à ça c'est genre parti
à enjeu et une nouvelle fois maxime qui
est mal alors qu'il ait jamais mal
maxime quasiment dans les ouvertures
c'est rare ouais mais bon là le tarn mal
je sais pas te dire c'est inconfortable
et m'aidera jok c'était vraiment
vraiment la cata
et merci à mookie keith abonnés avec
twitch prime merci tonton les pages de
vieux boom pour remercier tout de suite
et qui a pas qu'à spa qui nous demandent
pourquoi vous parlez de wasyl et socom
potentiels qualifiés pour les candidats
tout simplement poste qui fait part de
tes jouets mans peuvent encore
mathématiquement se qualifier
non mais le truc c'est qu'il a quatre
points vincent c'est peu mais en fait tu
peux marquer 12 points avec une victoire
sur le temps tu marques les bonus et que
tu gagnes le tournant la fin donc il
reste seize autres exprès pour l'instant
se qualifier et merci à nous y aura dix
abonnés avec twitch prime c'est son
deuxième mois d'abonnement merci tonton
merci mais ce qui demande son lit le
chat bah ouais on te répond à la
question en lisant le chat
justement après pour sow c'est assez
improbable foncé je pense qu'il a très
peu de chances mais s'il passe le
premier temps avec des points bonus
parce que le deuxième
ils vont finale et gagne la finale
marquent pas de points mais dix points
il a 14 et tu sais pas bonjour à gaza
qui nous dit bochy taceq aussi il a cinq
points au même on a aussi parlé bah oui
on a aussi parlé donc automatiquement
mais bon pense que soe plus dangereux
parce qu'ils lisent sens être
intrinsèquement plus fort mais
effectivement les deux peuvent donc prêt
très vite les deux peuvent de plus
aucune chance si maxime avant ce grand
des points bonus non mais aussi vraiment
ils ont plus pour rien ça c'est sûr mais
avant de tourner à dire même les mecs
qui ont un point peuvent
mathématiquement jouer pour se qualifier
bon là mais non vraiment un cas de
figure de fresnes mémoire mais moi mais
moi même pas banal et aveyron non mais
alors mois ci alors moi même 200 % parce
que
ge
j'ai la petite matriochkas poutine et
donc je peux peut-être tu vas pour une
wild card
donc je prétends je prétends quand même
encore femmes
c'est faux que faut pas non plus tu vois
me rayer de la liste
notre mois voire contre moi non non non
on va après est ce que n'est peau à la
bonne matriochkas escale excellent quoi
la bonne matt rust cas on ne sait pas
mais je tape à la porte pour pour ses
candidats bien évidemment donc tfc reiki
kevin wale quartier les candidats ce
serait beau t'imagines s'achèverait
extraordinaire non ce serait tellement
ridicule non ce bateau qu'à poutine en
fait j'aurais des ordis à l'intérieur à
fond quoi les arbitres me laisserais
ferris et une batterie repoussé par l'aï
touché dégage mais peut-être la troche
quatre morts svelte attaque quoi
carrément quoi ça porte bonheur
ouais ça me porte je suis très chanceux
avec cette masse coach k a j'ai beaucoup
de chance encore une partie parfaite
lachance banques et camille claus je
faisais plus de tourner un bossu fin
voilà aujourd'hui le prochain ce sera à
gibraltar
donc qu'est ce qui est à faire total of
c'est là quand même battu deux fois
maxime topalov c'est son client là
qu'est ce qui se passe quand un client
normalement tu le maltraite non le
fidélise tu fidélisera la chance j'avais
ce qu'il dit et les gens se plaignaient
de crabes michael cart
non mais en fait j'ai toujours pas
compris cette histoire que les gens se
connaissent pour kramnik là il était
quand même premiers non qualifiés allier
l'eau et non en fait il y était numéro
trois mondial au mouvement des candidats
2018 ex-champion du monde et ex-champion
du monde dressé un nombre que tu en sais
pas si on va chercher le mec qui
avez vous envie de relever que les
rafales de vent tu vas tu l'envoies
nommer les russes donc forcément mais
non de la chronique enfin je sais pas
c'était pas n'importe quoi oui qu'il
avait il a fait le jeu alors on nous
promet un refuge dilater spectacle on
nous propose
on va jouer un clan da pour les blancs
nous propose peut-être de faire h4 g4 de
sacrifier le cavalier pour réussir à
ramener la dame en attaque femmes
ouais mais disons que je vois que tana
ch3 je fais quelque chose contre tu fais
quoi du genre boss soit rouages de en
exemple bref soit 3 dany si je crée une
autre menace d'ailleurs quatre étoiles
trois bons menace de faire cavalier ou
quatre livres de chasse tout voilà
normand fait ce genre d'attaqué est le
problème fin c'est un truc que je sais
des joueurs débutants et j'aime bien
mais en fait vous pouviez que l'on joue
pas de coup les filets hier quand on
fait le sacrifice c'est pas parce qu'on
menace je crois que c'est imparable dont
quatre qui nous lâchent une info ben
ouais c'est à dire que une pièce c'est
un bon investissement
donc faut être assez sur soi mais il ya
trop de mer de défendre là des fois
c'est compliqué qui a peut-être qu'une
seule ligne qui peut prendre des risques
mais là bon lait blanc peut faire trop
de coups que je pensais que les gens
aient vraiment l'habitude d'un discours
comme celui là fab un adjectif
généralement qui qui caractérise un
petit peu cette attitude ne pas vouloir
que ça cogite et de pièces simples up le
thouet voir autant quand on en oublie tu
jouer pour le fun et c'est d'autant plus
dur que des coups précis de défense que
t'as pas le temps mais en partie lente
il va devoir venir quoi donc mais qui
est écrivent plus être en majuscules il
y avait ce commentateur et le hk jay
quatre points d'exclamation que les
proches des cas très profond gros
courage montré par le joueur
tous deux se traite de pleutres et c'est
bon un truc que j'adore faire quand
j'aurai des pièces et quand l'évêque va
les changer les dames après vos cheveux
avec elle juste une pièce de plus se
reposer sur ozap c'est normal non c'est
pas là bas c'est vrai qu'à l'époque où
les jambes comme sponsor n'a pas été
très bien vues communes
ça va juste très frais cachés cracher à
la gueule du pragmatisme ou coup c'était
beau l'époque mais non mais bon ces
trucs d'attac juste peu importe raincy
où j'ai juste pour le fun on s'en fiche
mais mes armes et tout le monde joue
pour le fun ici enfin dans le chatt là
je pense que des joueurs aiment qu'ils
sont là pour s'amuser
non mais le truc c'est que josh bowman
dainese un peu de tous les niveaux au
point des gens qui peuvent être maîtres
internationaux ou qui font dépendre un
bout d'os qui ont jamais pris de licence
dont je vois en fait on peut s'y profile
et c'est pour ça que je préviens que
j'ai juste des fois ça marche pas de
donner des pièces
donc il a fait 6 max ouais il a freiné
le 5 mai 200 tr candidats ici pour les
blancs n'ont battu votre emploi clapson
que la position s et se détériore en
plus petit à petit bon ça peut-être pas
mais elles s'améliorent contre voilà on
va dire ça comme ça ne s'améliore pas en
d2 c'est hyper logique parce que tu fais
un clin d'oeil europe
ouais non mesdames b2c hyper logique en
fait c'est un flic et aux quelque part
pas assez défiant ketty du coup
la méthode du fait des menaces ça passe
de calvillo 4 ou je ne sais quoi tu veux
appuyer peut-être cb4 donc tu fais une
pierre deux coups tu stop des 5
enfin c'est rare qu'un coup phase 3 en 1
et en plus si tu mets en plus sur la
règle intéressante de dire une dame
ainsi 13 plus qu'un foutu mais la dalle
sur la couleur sur la couleur opposée
j'ai pratiqué ouais bon pull à déjà dit
je la connaissais particulièrement du
coup tu as appris mais de lui paraît
logique
oui je suis remonté au-dessus dès 2005
grâce à tous ces conseils intéressants
proférées oui j'ai un fou sur 4 blanc je
vais mettre la dame sur noir est ce que
tu penses que tu qu'on pourrait appeler
ça la méthode bitstream bassa plus
contient cavaliers un final tu inscris
toi tu te mets le roi en opposition dans
les annales du cavalier c'est une
méthode non babouins sont quand même
deux points très mélodique
du coup tu l'emploi dans tout est dans
tout et tournoi quoi oui a dit que je
veux ce qui a rallié la petite annonce 5
rapidement nom de cases en diagonale ça
va j'ai bien vu quoi ils contrôlent il
aura beaucoup de mal à contrôler la casa
5 c'est un grand danger face à la
méthode mvl coiffe donc mais de mieux de
bien sûr ça semble être le mien moreno
ça sent franchement paix pouzin paris
j'imagine trop gris tout lâché lui dans
un jogging dégueulasse en train de
regarder la partie
en fait les russes font porter bien
porter un truc dégueulasse chez eux
c'est des joggings short qui arrive un
peu en dessous des genoux
non c'est au rythme d'un jogging toulon
ouais je sais pas
il aime bien un terrain tee shirts
manches et 1er en jogging qui arrive en
dessous des joues c'est un peu
caricatural mais la fed a mené 2 1
jusqu'à la rue les russes portent et
j'imagine bien gris tubes comme ça en
train de en train de regarder les
parties et rigoler neal katyal joue
encore 1 ou la fille ouais tu que je
regarde un homme en train de tomber
encore plus tard tout était fini mais ce
jour annonce à jouer à fond ça joue à
fond ça joue à fond mais toth un toit
très méthodique et des parties très
marrante d'ailleurs et katia elle a fait
quoi hier des ronces et ou pas la fidh
human bomb du monaco
bayer et d'égout khaleda quatre points
au bac on ne l'a gagnée contre continue
à bravo malheureusement elle remonte
allait bien et en plus c'est cariat
jallet 4e ex-aequo du cool marcotte
point conejo le marquer points non oui
mais de toute façon elle est fait est
fait partie des filles qui devrait se
qualifier donc en fait fin bladi je
crois qu'il est plutôt pourquoi donc
c'est un adversaire prend les points aux
autres c'est ça non vraiment ça va il y
avait bien en fond de tableau la fatigue
est là un point bas mais le problème
c'est tourner raconte ça c'est important
on sait que des pans forme tu te fais
rouler dessus portement tout le monde de
marquer des points comme toi tu souffles
jamais c'est pas un open ou bon d'aller
nous deux rondes sens tu va redescendre
vous des gens pas trop forte remontée
fait un mauvais tournoi mais ça va au
fond du trou totalement on va fermer
ce n'est pas en forme des bons enfants
tontouta dessus annoncé le grand
classique 1 voyez des parties sympa ou
en privé une compétition sympa ça joue
pas très loin à monaco ces gens là
région
tu vois là à les voir c'est possible
c'est vous seul ou tel de pain
écoute je sais pas je dis un truc d'oise
1,5
écoute je sais pas mais c'est c'est ça
doit être au centre de toute façon
monaco c'est pas grand jeu te dire
bas même si t'es pas au centre déclame
un sentiment c'était forcément central
team carmine rouen g8 logique il part de
ce courage désagréable tu es obligé et
maintenant avec les blancs ballotte
après adoption
mais beckham tout semblait intéressant
parce que tu veut stopper l'idée de
dessin 2d avec mathieu m vu que tu
prestreau le centre c'est saint quentin
et donc absent va être signée dans l
affaire des cinq sinon sont des quatre
je sais pas cette personne a un truc
genre c'est prendre et du fond du
cavalier ma région je crois je prends
mikado libre je prend du plomb tu fais
mais qu'at-il gt5 quand même battu
arrêter avec ça mais marc avait juste
pour dijon s'éprend de lui en prend
ouais tu prends en c5 et tuffet cavalli
à 4 août attaqué pcistes d'accès 5 déjà
c'est un problème et s'il n'ya même pas
besoin d'analyser cavaliers du cavalier
toute façon on prend direct et c5 est
déjà en mer histoire donc avec des
quatre en fait c'est un groupe en vue de
jouer dans l'absolu et qui en plus et
prophylactiques donc une pierre deux
coups du coup il va sûrement le jouer
puisque cfa c'est tellement logique en
plus bon peut-être beaucoup je sais mais
[Musique]
bon et pour le mans c'est pour le monde
b4 ou quoi ça à gérer pour le monde
topalov qu'il faille y maintient la
pression quoi mais c'est un boa
constrictor avril et il est quand même
pas en train de nous étouffer non c'est
un bois qui évolue il fait ça autre nom
est comme ça il fait une bonne partie de
leur c'est à dire que ceux des coûts
natural kouame mais il était non ils
jouent ils jouent correctement un effet
il fait vraiment une partie pour le
modèle après on va voir s'il réussit à
tenir le rythme
imposé par le français ne remet une
petite pub ce que j'ai envie
cyril qui pour l'instant mais
heureusement c'est topalov donc il va
finir par blender mais tiens je vous
pose une question en fait injuste contre
est ce que kébé ça qu'on peut faire boli
nécessaire un processus qui est
princesse
il est d'attaqué attisso personnes
jugeant retour recettes non mais je
précise à 8,6 pardon mais il va devoir
bricoler des pistes sont enfin je crois
c'est relou en fait ben je suis ma pote
à discuter et des sadristes des six donc
tu vaincras les âges cette madame sa
toile et ça le coude en résidence
jusqu'au cramé je crois
bah tu peux faire tout projet 7 rue des
buttes apporteront et non un cache cette
france et 6 2me processus qui est prince
est c'est quoi le problème c'est juste
un pion non ben en fait le truc bizarre
c'est que c'est pas la suggestion un des
ordis donc je n'ai eu aucun problème
et j'arrive à avoir fait boire la cij et
sans efforts des noms mais il faut lever
4,5
ils vont jouer aussi qui a et b 5e
vallée h7 est prise par ils sont
contents du tout en fait s'ils le font
bouffer de pions calmes parce que ça en
fait ça paraît qu'un logique de partir
confusion qui suit a pas un truc qui te
plantes direct lors il n'a pas joué
juste pour les gens qui ont vu sur
l'échiquier qui avance et je regardais
la ligne sur sur de chasse bombe et la
pagerie mais c'est vrai qu'il y avait
500 gagne en direct mais ce qu'elle est
si simple à gagner non rouge comprend
[Musique]
toutes actives nucléaire et c'est tout
ce que max ou non de la ligne à des
patates pour les banques mais c'est
intéressant c'est quand même pas des
saints dessin tu peux mais le bo 5 tu
vises h3g 2 et après tu lances dudit
54.4 une fois et dessins qui est ok
ouais tu actives c'est pas mal ça donc
c'est peut-être un petit fin piège peut
pas employer le mot piège pour ça mais
c'est peut-être une idée de max de
laisser deux pions volontairement et 2
deux bateaux qui ont provoqué topaloff
il dit qu'il allait forcer maximin bien
jouer un type x qui veut et en fait
ouais c'est après un rebond ce n'est
même pas le divan simplement
mais quand tu te prend que 5 des 5 et
qui la pétillante a bien place était
toujours et est ok ça tu vas revenir
voir jessains pouvoir bon après les
blancs restent au mieux un mais mais
c'est chaud j'ai pas des cinq sets
partout quoi menace de prendre ses 400
d2 c'est pas faux parents rofo paterson
avec les blancs n'ont pas ses vaches au
lieu de faire des quatre gardes tout
sous contrôle coûteront pas de contre
jeu et tu gardes peut-être la menace
pour un jour oui d'ailleurs mais ce que
tu penses que topalov peut tomber dans
le piège
je pense quoi moi je pense qu'il peut
tout cas il réfléchit trop longtemps là
t'as pas là c'est une bonne nouvelle
bah non mais s'ils tombent dedans et que
ce sera très bien pour max mais problème
c'est que c'est dieu si tu réfléchis tu
tu pousses la ligne et tu vois ça va je
re de faire juste un tout petit tour
vers les stades
bin hammam et bain en fait chacun stade
des coûts dont je suis un poil mieux
mais c'est la fin de cette partie
ouais non ça va ce serait bien qu'ils
tiennent iakovenko avec les noirs on
retourne sur maxime topalov qui prend du
temps topalov qui est en train de
peut-être laissé un petit peu passer sa
chance fab
bah écoute on verra le shaq fu qui joue
en fait soutenir si jouer gâte pour le 5
juin
jusqu'à ce coup là en tout cas vincent
c'est des bons coups qui joue et il n'a
pas encore joué les cinq français six
boucles alors qu'on nous dit que guy en
gros danger plus de vous pour vous en
parler
on vous en parlait
avant le avant le début de la partie on
disait guy rivo nuit hier en demi pour
mme amène un ami na na na hey dit guéri
il a déjà restauré puissant ya loïc
dugué riz qui prend son avion demain
comme prévu mais j'ai bien peur que oui
ou non après je m'attendais pas ce
qu'ils perdent dans les parties lentes
blanchet null null null adieu les
rapides allemand de ce qui a aidé 5 est
jouable ici comprendre comprendre h1
bottes sacs et même des quatre qui est
peut-être joueurs voient leurs dégâts de
ces minerais
je pense oui ça maintient un avantage
blanc quand même si on joue comme ça je
sais pas quelque chose qui me fait dire
que c'est pas naturel de faire ça on
peut qu'aider 5e voudrais juste aussi
faire du voyage soft matter sky at night
je peux être échangé un quelle est la
perte du cavalier je sais pas je pensais
qu'il voulait faire ça et des cendres
ouais ça pas grand intérêt en fait ce
nom mais b4 et beaucoup logique fabregas
est sûre ce soir
qu'est-ce que j'ai 4 c'est une idée pour
les blancs oui sa peine oui mais la
semaine mais on peut vouloir le préparer
en faisant rage 2 pour un peu contre les
aphtes wave 3 et 4 mais l'idée de b4 on
le rappelle l'idée de fab avec bkc
d'empêcher des cinq ans mettant la
pression sur ses seins qu'on vous l'a
montré il ya quelques minutes
wen octas sa première chose deuxième
truc tu forces noires à regarder tout le
temps dépensé 5 chaque coup puisque
c'est un problème donc pour l'instant
pas tellement tu fais des prend et
sattouf la colonne des mais imaginons
plus tard dans la partie et petits ainsi
sous-poids denjean structure a4 a5 qu'il
ya un souci est pourri c'est rare d'y
attacher les services trempé 5 pour une
raison x ou y
ouais tu va taper la chaîne de pions 6b
français des français la colonne belles
lettres pour nous on a le fou qui aident
à rentrer en bessin toutefois donc en
fait c'est juste toujours agréable quand
on crée une sorte de tension
d'imposition et qu'on contrôle quand on
la garde quand on est à leur vote et
développe décide de prononcer 5 ses
longues de faire des simples ou de rien
faire alors qu'arras lieu de jouer
j'imagine fable que l'idée c'est de
faire bouger ce cavalier pour jouer g4
est peut-être parti range étroit pour
mettre la pression sur h5 qui en parlait
tout à l'heure face de ce pion et c'est
vrai que si le lion peuvent y 1 h 4 on
pourra revenir après que lecavalier et
se crée une nouvelle cible
je pense que c'est l'idée fable de ce
coup cavale yeux de chez pas si je vais
bien résumé le résumé je voudrais avoir
l'avis du grand maître qui sommeille en
toi
ouais non mes salaires c'est le cas
alors est ce que ça marche je sais pas
quel poids parce qu'en fait maxime va
croire que son contrôle joël dessaint
dan kavanagh h7
admettons un hook rsr boîte 7g cache
cette zac
edison cavani g3 et h4 quand même
j'imagine un homme
je pense que tu dois plutôt fait rage ag
keyna laisse mon voyage prévu et rouge
tanger un vent violent avec lada en b2
qui attaque très loin mais l'élan
d'abord le chômage pour songer qu'à ça
l'est moins triables leurs besoins et
joe dessins paraissent que t'as pas peur
d'un plan à base de roy f2 tour h1 qui
menacent ils avaient moins c'est bon
pour le coup on consomme trop je vais
changer ainsi qu'à vous faire d'écart
faire des choses alors admettons que je
fasse trois f2 tu va peut-être jouer des
4 as des quatre sports pas con kerry qui
va revenir et fils qui va taper les
cases doit être non ça paraisse à paris
de +54 soir tout autour
qu'est ce que c'est si bien joué de la
part de total alors peut-être qu'il va
pas jouer g41 non pas si tu fais b4
malgré tout à ce moment là oui à noter
que l'ordi sur cavaliers eu deux cars et
les achètent ils proposent cavalli ses
trop rares et cavaliers v6 est donc
savourer ça pourrait fab bavoirs alors
ils aspect car il a joué déclaré ok il
ya une autre idée on épargne
voilà alors je suis pas je suis pas
mécontent bon je préférais le point de b
cargo est en écoute je suis pas
mécontent à première vue alors
évidemment les blancs restent mieux mais
ça permet de rentrer dans quelque chose
des pions prend des quatre tempo
d'ailleurs l'ordi a pas du tout aimé
cette série de coups de la part de nos
faveurs du joueur bulgare
quoique il dit sur cavaliers prend des
quatre les blancs garde comme un bel
avantage et je sais pas moi j'ai
l'impression que c'est comme une énorme
amélioration pour les noirs bas d'un
truc où tu bouges ehpad en train
d'enlever des pièces de gibier
donc tu aides le camp kalma des espaces
oui après votre tête juin et audemars
auxi et que 4 et mais non ça reste qu'à
mieux pour les blancs mais j'ai
l'impression que c'est moins parce que
tu es en train de transformer dans un
phare montois sont toujours obligés de
transformer pour transport un avantage
les jambes sont que t'as pas tape après
76 mam avec les blancs après dans ma
d'éclat de sa nouveauté russe ouais
bizarre comme juin après tu as droit de
prendre du poisson des fins comprend que
les ventes et prendre aussi le jeu pas
trop ce que tu veux faire mais tu gardes
un contrôle on est déçu de faire céder
cap des 5 à 4 5
quand même mieux un mais des changements
soient plaints d'être comme ça j'ai
planté un froncé si ce n'est pas moi
écoute c'est la première bonne nouvelle
du jour dans la partie joueurs français
mais ça fait moins peur que moins que b
on dit dans le chatt qu'un marotti sans
énormes pièces sur l'échiquier ça fait
pas peur c'est toujours désagréable même
quand même peu de pièces mais c'est vrai
que ça se tient bon la deuxième bonne
nouvelle c'est que la pièce casto blanc
c'est le challenge qui peut la pièce
phare - 6 1
pascal des quatre une impression
stratégique bécade plus logique parce
que à taxer 5 avec un pion de l'alouette
tout à fait c'est c'est un choix étrange
de la part du joueur bulgare femme
vraiment joueur bulgare qui nous aura
pas vraiment impressionné dans ces
matches contre maxime
bah oui je le trouve à un moment il a
une belle ni noms ni les vaillants toi
il est pas là tout le sens du landy coup
il est là les bijoux kouame mais il a
hâte pas garder le niveau long arrêt non
il n'y arrive pas bon après on va voir
ce que là c'est encore fini la partie
le petit bada bon il c'est curieux aussi
qu'il reprenne pas tempo je suis
d'accord et s'il a mis autant de temps
jeu qui a valu aux deux cépages sont
déjà passés quasi 20 minutes pour sur
des quatre palmarès se demander de quoi
tu reprends c'est étrange mais à moins
qu'il ya un truc qui brandit la langue
jouer je sais pas laquelle est là il se
rend compte qu'un truc qui cloche
mais je vois pas courant mais ouf qui
manque d'ambition de topalov non non non
pas vraiment c'est plus ce manque de mon
manque de puissance de calcul manque de
jeu c'est pas moi comment appeler ça
manque de niveau tout bêtement un temps
propose france et 6 intermédiaire hall
alors ça je serais pas considérer ce que
j'aurais eu peur que mon roi deviennent
faibles fab toujours de me prendre
ils sont à combien de temps il reste 45
minutes chacun pour écoute pour le
moment faible la partie s'annonce moins
mal que qu'il n'y paraissait encore
quelques minutes mais il va quand même
falloir tenir s'ils jouent comme ça
qu'il prend qui est pression prend cette
position tout de même un petit peu
désagréable avec web et quatre baies 5 à
4 à 5 qui peut arriver pour pour faire
du jeu allèles allèles dame
ouais aussi trouver quoi quoi faire du
quadrillage cet égard il a son cavalier
à la bombe il souffrait bien dans ma
jeunesse
finalement on dirait qu'il a mis en rage
c'est très bon rennes peut arriver nous
sommes sont à nouveau très confiant a
toujours très confiant notre confiance
n'a pas de limites
alors est-ce qu'on nous pose une
question propre à la fin à 44 ans
comparaît amv elle qui à 29 ans il n'a
plus autant de puissance de calcul c'est
vrai gâchis
non mais t'as de tous face à ces c'est
relativement voile mais c'est une
histoire c'est une motivation
topalov en fait il a eu ses heures de
gloire elle était numéro un mondial
c est un moment en fait c'est juste dur
20 jeux réussis mais de continuer
toujours à faire des efforts et devenir
grand de la théorie est depuis une
équipe de seconde en et travailler et
refaire de calcul et de refaire le livre
d'autres assis sur une finale et mâche
pas clairement tu as fais tout ça et
voilà donc là tous peuvent le faire ces
petits tournois parce que je pense qu'il
aime bien jouer aux échecs miens jeu et
c'est tout mais qu'ils aient pu tous les
efforts pour être au top mais bon ben
voilà comment ça tu perds un niveau en
deçà mais c'est tu es bien humain dire
que c'est pas n'est pas un vishy anand
non non il est plus il est plus sa
version steam id plus fort il ya dix ans
il ya 15 ans en clamant là il tient plus
sa diète qua non mais c'est à dire un
truc marrant échec c'est que on pourrait
être amené à croire que plus tu vieillis
plus tu apprends de choses ce qui
fondamentalement est vrai en fait donc
plutôt une grande connaissance et donc
plus tu veux venir former en fait plus
non qu ben en fait je pense qu'à un
moment tu as assez appris ce que tu vas
prendre en plus après c'est un peu
anecdotique et tu perds beaucoup trop en
motivation et choses comme ça et ça te
fait baisser son niveau
t'oublies peut-être aussi un petit peu
ouais tu peux supplier tout avec
médisanté plus érudits metea moins bon
joueur il est en train d'arriver ou pas
du coup voir déclarant je sais je suis
motivé à presse
moi j'étais pas dans la classe des
genres topalov ou quoi c'est pas le
problème mais mais çà et là tout le
monde je pense
mais d'ailleurs vous posez la question
tu vois pourquoi il est des mecs qui est
ko des échecs on range pas fontaine
miralles jeu pas plein de grands maîtres
français ils ont disparu assez tôt
d'ailleurs un robert robert rien était
vraiment au 1/3 que way est en fait donc
ils peuvent encore jouer quelques
parties d'interclubs ou quoi partie par
là mais je comprends également tout à
fait le tour en fait tu as obtenu petit
le plus ok grand maître tout pour plus
rien d'autre tu sais qu'il sera pas
champions du monde sont d'avis de
conscience et au final qu'est ce que tu
fais un va donc te donner d'autres
jeunes gens la vie faire autre chose
finalement je comprends ouais mais tu en
avais tu en a quelques-uns qui en qui
ont arrêté un complètement des gravats
temps a cité deux noms mais vire même
vallée niveau mondial kasparov arrêté à
42 ans crâne ricard était quasiment
images etc
en fait c'est juste un moment tout à
fait autour de la question je pense tu
pourrais continuer à jouer et rami qui
serait sûrement encore top 10 qu'elles
soient recomptés arrêtait du bras
mondiale il aurait pu continuer de top
10 pendant un long moment mais c'est
beaucoup d'efforts et en fait t'as juste
plus le la niaque trois lecteurs bon ben
voilà donc fait un all star game
il ya aussi joël lautier a comme le dit
pas qui tu aurais fini mon nom mais en
fait donc il ya beaucoup de jours je
trouve ça assez logique en quelque sorte
un finalement ben ouais mais sûr et bon
voilà tout donc topalov lui il n'a pas
pris sa retraite officiellement mais un
peu comme si les semi retraités voilà
pas moi je vous sers comme ça c'est un
peu d'un copain va faire qu'il aille
faire la grève là parce qu'ils vont qui
n'a pas encore l'âge heureux qu'il a
point fr est il mal la whey mais bon
peut-être qu'il va arriver à faire des
petites si nous donner des petits
machins et qui qui pu cotiser à sa
manière juste à cliquer ci carrassan
perdre son titre est pour rien arrêter
les échecs ça m'étonnerait pas vrai
qu'ils arrêtent s'y perd le titre ibo
c'est ce qu'il avait dit l'an dernier
bon chemin
euh oui mais bon ce vin non mais ça me
paraît pas incroyable d'arrêter à 35 40
ans 1
oui même pas 30 ans n'a peut-être pas
perdre le titre
et là encore ça j'ai eu le temps de le
garder non mais tu peux aussi ça doit
être aussi une nouvelle motivation
d'aller rechercher le titre oui oui ça
peut être aussi une autre motivation est
aussi un autre challenge
par contre s'ils commencent à perdre le
titre est à avoir est de voir aller
rechercher des qualifs au candidat il
pourra plus de mal bon la première fois
tu es des qualifiés d'office aux
candidats mais géré par s y perd le
titre que l'année d'après il rate
laquelle il faut qu'enfin les candidats
romands n'ont même pas parler d'eux et
tout son ensemble
oui bien sûr on demandait la cadence et
une heure trente plus 30 secondes par
coup jusqu'au 40e après il ya rajouté
une demi-heure ou une heure j'ai déjà
oublié
je dirais en dessous de 30 minutes après
non c'est une bonne cadence je trouve
une heure trente plus 40 coups 30
secondes au 40e c'est bien c'est mieux
que ce qu'ils vont donc il ya eu prise
dans le cas de prise le 4 et cavaliers
qui est revenu en f 6 est donc là cette
pollution ont parlé d'un coup tu avais
l'idée pour les blancs de bk de baies 5
pouces et si c'est peut-être à 4 à 5
mais ça nous paraissait loin d'être
catastrophique côté noir
enfin maxime qui semble avoir bien
amélioré sa position sur les derniers
coups topalov qui a pas été patient un
finalement bizarre étrange 10,2 vraiment
l'être vous inscrire si vous aimez comme
tu disais tu es tu là motive il a il et
il a réussi un certain âge et un bon
passage à mettet sont profondes
c'est de jouer des trucs passions
s'étaient de palafittes d'agora les
parties très chaud très compliqué ou via
l'énergie aussi dans le jeu il faut
c'est nage d'or vous à une époque
l'adresse des filets qualité là dans
tout l'ouest indienne il a gagné plein
de belles parties et a donc savoir très
dynamique
c'est vrai alors dans une position tout
à une telle assise tu peux tu peux aussi
la jouer plus tranquillement et à c'est
plus facile de mai tranquille manquantes
et mieux que quand tu es moins bien quoi
non mais là on parle plus tout ce qu'on
a raconté
il est bien au courant alors sache un
ami qui a une armée qui a fait sortir
les joueurs de la salle à un moment si
d'autres personnes ont des infos ça peut
expliquer le temps de réflexion et ça
peut être du coup expliqué le carré lieu
de un peu mauvais ou pourquoi leur prix
ils en trois ans d'écart ouais marrant
ça j'aime arriver une femme une alarme
activement de sécheval france à caen en
jouer en nationale b mais j'avais les
noirs contre happy c'est la norme moment
ça va sonner on a dû évacuer la salle je
passe alerte incendie bon y'a pas du
tout chaud pour refaçonner le c'est
comme ça et once d'or 15 20 minutes
il est dû à mousse spéciale qui fait
quoi en fait
on a juste repris les parts ou de
s'endetter mais ce qui était censée
redémarrer à zéro
en fait là tu es dehors du monde parle
avec tout le monde c'est le fouillis
ils peuvent en plus tu peux voir ton
téléphone sur toi c'était pas encore le
truc de la parano ou d'être posée l'été
faudra mais partout quoi donc
n'importe qui peut peut-être avec son
téléphone a battu tata mille personnes
doivent donc c'est n'importe quoi parce
que je veux dire en fait je n'ai pas de
limites seraient partisans pour
recommencer à zéro la partie mais bon
c'est un peu dégueulasse site était
mieux et que j'ai que ça donne une
deuxième chance à dire ça non mais c'est
un truc bizarre hein c'est juste je sais
pas quelle serait la bonne décision à
prendre en fait non je reprends de
regarder inscrits dans le chatt c'était
il ya 35 minutes nous disent il va donc
pourquoi est-ce que maxime ne joue pas
eu cinq sur ces 4 au premier coup ah oui
et pas de raison d'un c'est juste ok
déjà prêts à l'économie à mon avis de
d'énergie de travail parce que sur quels
élèves 3 3 pages veut ça
donc il est marié depuis il joue ses
cinq médailles à ces quatre donc déjà
avant ta ce premier truc donc ça te fait
faire un double répertoire vraiment les
gens aiment pas facile car quand tu
travailles un truc qui tient ce afin
d'avoir une vente sur un truc une notion
une autre mais au final si ça devient
trop problématique
ainsi m et du coup sûr car il est fort
fera pas qu'il fasse ses 5
vous savez il préfère un répertoire
beaucoup plus vaste
mais je sais pas c'est ça la raison
fondamentale après la deuxième c'est que
ces 4 c 5 c'est quand même veine une
faute c'est juste une touche symétrique
qui sens est le meilleur en fait en
général de 4,5 des quatre des cinq c4 c5
et donc il est plutôt du genre à croire
à ses ventes avec sylvain distin qui
colle très bien fait d'attendre qu'ils
la jouent avec nos nouvelles pareil donc
il lâche pas facilement après s'il ya un
moment il ya plus rien à faire ils me
rendre à l'évidence il est rarement
foutu juste à cause de la turquie
ouais là c'est juste qu'on ait eu le cas
on a eu le cas de figure de position où
il est moins bien depuis depuis quelques
quelques temps sur ces quatre îles à de
vrais problèmes ils nous avaient pas
habitués à avoir de tels problèmes dans
l'ouverture
non mais bon ok ou la pose la question
sur la neige dans un fossé d'eau sur la
lune feld aussi quand il est perdu cours
de magnus chez + dvd glad
et puis qu'on aimait dire en finale à
riga ouais on met cette année un pet oui
mais la démocratie 80 c'était autre
chose c'était des cards à tout ça peut
arriver défaut nous demande si en tant
que joueur 2e 4 avec ses 4,5 t'as pas un
répertoire gratuit oui mais c'est
l'inversé mais le temps des cars fait
une grosse différence
ça change vraiment tout ben tiens tu
peux avoir déjà fait impression mais en
fait déjà tout l'éventail grand roque
t'oublie quoi porte nous c'est plus du
tout bas donc déjà c'est juste deux
choses différentes
un peu ça déjà même si les blancs parce
que retour à faire à 3 en fait c'est un
bon outil de la sicilienne
donc c'est si jamais juste là donc en
fait en général je vous sais 4,5 avec
mal de ventes avec fougue et 4 15 0 sol
imoca ouais c'est ça plus simple et
sorte de roche au liban ou ou sinon
c'est dragon accélérer un verset jarre
tc3 kenichi ce cavalier f3 calisesi ce
g3 et aux kennedy 5 cc c'est un wagon
accéléré avec un temps de plus pour les
plans c'est ça donc ça change vraiment
tout mais oui donc c'est pas par un ciel
toujours habituellement c'est pas les
nages d'art proposées serre est un
commencement mais bien pour moi c'est
juste c'est 4 5 très correct pour un
prêt c'est l'histoire de goût donc
topalov vient de jouer 3 h 2 il enlève
son roi de cette diagonale qui pouvait
s'ouvrir mois un coup juste utile dans
l'absolu voilà c'est logique
alors on dit que l'ordi propose h 4 dans
le chat mais il a fait rager 7 mai h4
c'est moi j'aurais jamais fait j'aurais
peur de g4 damev deux dames princes 4 ça
peut être un coup kim aurait attiré fab
nhk tranquillement a été noire un
non-match des brigades se disant c'était
la recommandation de l'ordi mais
n'importe quoi donc maxime qui a fait
roi g7 par contrat g7 s'est pas un coup
j'aurais fait non plus il a fait des
cartes tempo je sais pas j'aime pas du
tout ce visage bien j'aime pas trop
mettre dans un clouage après peut-être
que j'ai tort dans le sens où je le fais
vraiment jamais et du coup je me limite
1 mais je déteste avoir ce vis-à-vis une
épée de damoclès
ouais j'ai l'impression qu'un jour ça va
me poser problème me servais soit qu'ils
saluent kevin salut fab on voit tous les
jours on vous voir tous les jours ces
temps ci coule en tout cas on est gâté
bah écoutes je viens de voir encore
jusqu'à la fin du mois et puis après tu
vas - nous voir battre une grotte sur
youtube mais moins - dans les lives des
commentaires de partir plus gros tournoi
envie de dire période de pause la
janvier février mais on réattaque
rappelé un de plein des naseaux son
bilan pour les candidats wii qui sera
le plus beau tournoi quand même les
candidats il match pour le titre fade
c'est les deux gros événements
en gros candidat c'est le plus beau
tournoi parce que le match marathon en
cinq matches ouais donc le qualificatif
de plus beau tournoi n'est pas galvaudé
ça va je ne galvaude pas non j'aime ça
ce sera je crois et je crois que ça
commence le 17 mars du coup j'avais eu
le cas le 15 c'est arrivé delhaize
c'est très difficile avec les tournois
d'échecs de serre vraiment le jour de
début de tournoi parce que tu sais
parfois ils te mettent le jour de la
première ronde des foies et de mettre le
jour d'arrivée des foyers de mettre le
jour de la cérémonie d'ouverture est
pareil genre en fait là de base y avait
écrit du 10 au 24 et en fait mais pas
celui du rose bonbon mais en fait j'ai
jamais vu ça de ma vie nulle part mais
du coup au fait on est intéressés
qu'eurosport ce qu'on savait pas ce
qu'on devait dire parce qu'en fait on
savait être enfin je dis oui ils ont
fait le tour du monde 23 oui mais je
sais que le site officiel est dit que
c'est du 10 au 24 mai en réparant dit le
vrai truc où on dit comme eux et puis
voilà et on a pris le parti de dire
comme eux il faut bien le dire on prend
les infos qui a écrit ça médard l'eau
très bonne nouvelle frappe c'est que si
jamais il y avait un départage décisif
pour la qualification aux candidats il
se jouera bien évidemment le lundi 23
s'attendre à pas un dimanche
histoire d'être sûr que ce moment
décisif de la saison soit un jour où les
gens bien sûr lundi 14 heures c'est
exactement l'horaire où on peut avoir
deux le dénouement est je pense un peu
le moment ciblées donc ça va on l'a vu
on a eu du mal avec le grand duché est
sourd on s'était mis un dimanche mais là
on a repris tout de suite les bonnes
habitudes
bizarre mais est-ce que c'est justement
parce que une grande chasse tour et que
ça clashe avec l'inde et que le
calendrier que vous pouvez pas commencé
avec un jour de décalage
non je pense pas ça soit les
conseillères en fait battue commence
vraiment me disent ça rentre pour vous
je finis dimanche 22 oui mais il avait
déjà fait pour les autres grands prix de
finir à lundi à wama j'arrive j'arrive
toujours pas à comprendre la raison
profonde mais bon c'est comme ça c'est
comme ça on s'est habitué à force 1
qu'est le stratège derrière ça c'est un
grand stratège
c'est pour se démarquer des autres
sports et qu'au plus tard c'est celle
jouée par max et la prochaine est fixée
à début je crois c'est le 6 à 19 heures
elle aussi janvier déjà bien ouais ça
attaque tout s'est passé mais non c'est
bien trop mettant voyez la liste des
joueurs ou encore boucheron ça va être
des joueurs j'ai pas mis fin je suis
tranquille quoi nan men deadline nous
faut qu'on présente une liste définitive
on est jean cartier jarre 16 joueurs non
non non t'es pas cap et à la tuque en
mètre cinquante et un nom tkp par hello
je crois que t'as pas le droit plus de
quatre joueurs au dessus de 2007 et 8
joueurs au sud 2006 ou quelque chose
comme ça genre tu peux pas te s'amuser à
mettre tout le monde dans l'équipe pour
que les deux équipes lésées par à quoi
mais bon comme j'ai déjà dit
valises et de s'amuser avec l'équipe de
france ou quoi mais moi personnellement
à titre très personnel le changement de
format
me réjouis pas spécialement parce que
j'en parlais hier sur le live mais ça va
être de nouveau les mêmes compétitions
avec les mêmes joueurs qu'on voit tout
au long de l'année et des lives
j'avais calculé depuis juillet je crois
qu'il ya déjà eu quasiment 100 live deux
parties en direct
donc à un moment donné tu vas avoir 150
jours les mêmes joueurs jouent entre eux
s'est même 200 jours dans la neige ou
non mais un moment en fait je sais pas
s'ils voient pas l'intérêt quoi ce qu'il
ya d'étonnant fin je suis d'accord mais
c'est que la prod geste il limite la
première année c'était le meilleur rang
après année c'était le mieux ré quart
mais en fait c'est très rare que tu es
un truc et tulle empire d'année en année
que d'habitude tu fais des mises à jour
greg des tur entretenir
ouais mais j'aimais bien côté local
c'était vraiment que quand tu fais un
vrai club local or après bien sûr locale
ça peut être dans un ring 300 kilomètres
je comprends parce que c'est logique
mais mais ça avait plus de sens pas
d'avoir une équipe bombe à moustey
cannes mais met donc des gens qui
avaient un lien avec kanouté pas trop
loin et que chaque club soit un peu
comme ça t'as droit à un agent et à la
rigueur un joueur sur quatre est là pour
plus de 2 tu fais là la moyenne à 2500
c'était pas mal cet ancêtre moyen trouvé
des petites pépites soit des jeunes de
trouver des ailes et jocelyne fait
baisser un peu la moyenne ou des choses
comme ça qu'il faudrait une bonus c'est
cool mais cette force être un peu
créatif et ça faisait jouer des gens
qu'on voit pas forcément je suis prêt
puis ça a fait passer des bons moments
je me rappelle par exemple la saison
dernière le moment où où cette joie rdda
qu'est le gars tu rappelles il a défendu
une position indéfendable ould cheikh en
fait tu vas mettre un vrai pro il va
jamais aussi heureux que seb avait été
heureux quand il avait gagné ça a été
vraiment très heureux nier cette partie
est du coup sa joie elle était
communicatif pour tout le monde mais
c'est ça puis c'était plus bande de
potes quoi ouais ouais [ __ ] avait
c'était rafraîchissant les mecs ces gens
qui n'ont pas du tout l'habitude d'être
médiatisé jouer des trucs donc c'est une
compétition importante pour eux là ça va
juste être une compétition de plus et et
une deuxième règle qui me qui me déplaît
beaucoup là encore à titre personnel
c'est que ok on a voulu faire par pays
voire très bien j'aime beaucoup cette
règle en fait mais on va avoir le droit
à deux étrangers oui donc c'est plus bas
sur quatre donc soit on fait vraiment
par pays par pays et du coup je
comprends petit peut-être de faire des
modes un mode olympiades sur internet en
rapide parce que ça n'existe pas mais là
encore peut-être cool mais là du coup tu
vas jouer par pays et par exemple et
chaises bras canada vont avoir gris
choco premier fear aux jo deux week-ends
équipe canada le canada la chance
donc j'ai rien contre eux tant mieux
qu'ils aient des bons joueurs et bravo à
eux
et c'est bien qu'ils puissent avoir les
moyens financiers avec avec les dons et
c'est de payer ces joueurs là c'est tant
mieux mais c'est bien pour gucci etc
mais je trouve que du coup en fait le
truc qui était bien dans cette formule
là c'était dire ouais c'est par pays et
de faire des genre de compétition rapide
par pays officieuse ou même officiel
d'ailleurs dans quoi est cool et là en
fait non en fait non donc du coup mais
oui je peux faire comme ce tome tout
début oui oui moi aussi mon équipe là la
première saison était clairement
clairement la mieux des recettes et
salué le plus d'audience il y avait le
plus de hype ne soit mais le format
était cinq ans ils vont il ya le côté
novateur au 6 mai mais en fait bizarre
et mais bon là pour cette nouvelle
formule du coup moi le truc qui me
chagrine vraiment du coup s'ils ont
voulu changer ok pourquoi pas en faisant
part pays parce qu'ils veulent un peu
changé le truc mais le truc des deux
étrangers sur quatre ça me paraît énorme
oui sur quatre déjà même je serais même
ordre et justice pis mais sur 4 pourquoi
parler d'eux sur quatre c'est pas de
faire ça plus aucun rapport donc voilà
petite déception par rapport à ça près
on participera à nous du pour le coup on
va jouer le truc à fond on aura une
équipe all french web et l'équipe donc
au moins si on gagne on pourra vraiment
dire qu'on est l'équipe de france donc
du coup nous on va rester dans l'esprit
qu'on aurait qu'on aurait voulu avoir
donc ce sera cool dont on aura une vraie
équipe de france mais on se battra à
armes inégales faso face aux autres mais
on aura mvl et bacrot donc et
et maxime la gare déjà étroits les trois
numéros un numéro 2 et numéro 3 français
et je peux te dire tu vois on n'a pas
besoin d'aller c'est à dire que tu
prends gris chirugien oui mais moi je te
pose le foie gras une nouvelle fois
c'est en fait je te même vl et et
backrooms je suis quand même plus fort
que toi tu vasculaire c'est moi j'ai pas
besoin de prendre d'étrangers je suis
français et donc du coût supérieur et
après 11,3 tu peux mettre le numéro
kavanagh canadien chez maxim lagarde
tokyo maxime la garde de son lit et déjà
plus fort que toi tu vois cette sur un
moment donné si tous les mecs vont
vouloir nous opposer des étrangers et
nous on va leur mettre des gérard
depardieu et on va leur dire j'ai le
plus grand acteur du monde je t'emmerde
donc à un moment donné ça va se passer
comme ça et aux quatre on va sûrement
avoir soit yannick soit soit mathieu
soit mazaugues lufa qu on aura encore du
monde si tu en auras un quatrième gérard
donc sinon ça va être la france face au
monde entier
et là on va se rendre compte que
waterloo
voilà quoi tiens ça c'était avant
on va on va te parler d'austerlitz situe
à ce que je veux dire donc on va un peu
tôt posé ça et donc ce sera quand même
tu vas en fait on sera la seule équipe
kouyou de la compétition je te
l'annoncent déjà on va être les seuls tu
vois a déjà posé tu vois sur la table
donc voilà un peu le discours d'avant
match si tu veux tu vois tu sens que bon
on est grand favori de la compétition
bien évidemment donc que les autres
soient en sueur parce qu'on va on va
leur opposer on va leur opposer la bonne
bouffe française mais avoue que c'est
une belle équipe c'est ici s'ils ont
besoin mais qui va très bien gérard
bacrot contre fil rouge à genre à
rigoler on va rigoler 2 minutes 1 c'est
ça va être du qua non met à son compte
tous les joueurs façon d'un max c'est
super les deux maxime petit matin du
maxi mais j'avais un objectif type qui
peut s'asseoir notre table maîtres de
maxime bain des gens de voir un point de
bonus ouais ben tu vois un corner taux
quatre fois joueur qui peut s'asseoir à
la table et dire je suis mieux préparé
que toi ça va être fantastique cornetto
oui au 18e coup à tiens tu fais une
petite imprécisions gelé dans le fichier
quoi match ans c'est en fichiers dégage
tu es déjà moins bien je ne sais pas
jouer quoi tellement dommage que vlad ne
revienne pas dans les kitchen stories
vlado quatre semaines extraordinaires il
a pour nom le mettre dans la liste juste
pour rien il a dit ce jeu est une drogue
très dangereux je ne dois plus jamais
jouer la moindre partie mais il est très
dangereux en fait comme il a très très
peur d'abord s'ils veulent une partie
seront allés à payer il a fait une
petite partie d'entraînement avec son
élève les médias incroyable j'ai perdu
ma dit le début de match c'était genre
2-2 quoi c'est incroyable je vais très
mal bon après j'ai gagné 10,2 ça allez
quoi mais j'ai dit oui elle joue un
petit peu comme toi mais bien pire
d'ailleurs c'est toujours oui beaucoup
on m'a dit incomparable toi tu comprend
un petit peu quoi moi ça va je le
comprend un petit peu bah je connais les
règles du jeu je me bats quoi le jour
chez ben laden b2g 2
couleurs je pense que pour la plus
encore prise en passant petit robe grand
roc face à il maîtrise qu enfin un bon
un bon grand maître à 2005 j'aurais dit
quoi je connais tous les coups c'est
pourquoi c'est à partir de 2000 alors à
2300 tu sais à peine bouger les pièces
quoi tu suis à fond calcule donc j'aurai
un peu le chat que j'ai pas mal trop
laid ce qu'ils disent est complètement
ouf ce vlad
ouais ouais en fait l'équipe de france
n'est pas un ange et notre équipe est
très forte en fait il faut le savoir et
peut-être fab bafa peut-être jouera de
temps en temps mais je ne sais pas trop
je me mets dans le jt puis je vois je
joue je joue non mais je crois tu es
juste pas trop là en fait pendant la
période
en gros ben là je compte faire
guadeloupe gibraltar déjà janvier fois
qu'on dit sur moi février un peu plus
mais après j'ai le tournoi à djerba non
loin
donc j'aurai quelques d'atrium dispo
mais pas tout le temps en hand sivan
était vraiment formalité 18e mondial je
pense qu'on d'europe car tennis de coupe
du monde et 18e mondiale donc oui bon ça
répond à la question va prendre mais
quoi qu'il en soit le fait qu'ils soient
champions d'europe qu'il était champion
d'europe lui lui donne quand même l'un
des plus beaux si ce n'est le plus beau
palmarès français mais plus en activité
maintenant ça fait 5 3 il faut boire je
pense est très bien joué en bas si ça
marche oui je sais pas je déteste cette
phrase taiwan nan mais c'est que moi
très froide et prendre le dessin
décrivent manger milan ac 5 quand elle
est de bien bosser sans trop qu'on passe
à la question si ça marche que tu fasses
des biens tout échange était très
heureux ce prêt tu fais h4 défonce le
roi je comprends le concept mais si tu
te prends des 5 c 5 des 6 et 6,5
donc tu vois ma première vue je peux pas
dire si c'est parce qu'ils coupable de
jouer c'est un coup très
on sable alors il ya eu f2 tempo mais
qui est des cinq je suis sûr qu'on peut
faire ça va ça va partir en queue debout
dans l'ain ou en eau de boudin ou je
sais pas ce que tu veux mais ça c'est un
truc un rapport avec du boudin la fab
dire que ça a du sens ouais je viens de
penser à un truc là qui n'a aucun
rapport
c'était bien la chanson c'est le roi
dagobert qui a mis sa culotte à l'envers
jeu ouais je sais pas tout d'un coup en
fait la structure c'est qu'ils match je
sais pas pourquoi tu vois c'est fou donc
tu voulais des paroles non non je veux
juste vérifier ce que tout d'un coup en
fait j'ai pensé à ça je sais pas
pourquoi qui est musique de danse et
reprennent des noms mais il paraissait
loin dagobert mais non tout d'un coup je
me suis posé la question mais cette
heure c'est m et puis je sais pas
pourquoi cette chanson vous être un truc
moyenâgeux dans le comté des machins et
chanter mes chansons en simple j'ai
remis une petite pub les gens su dans le
chat un chat hier l'arrêt des petits
plus comme ça tu vas de temps en temps
des petits achats d'actifs
et si de plus pourquoi non mais pour la
pub pour le coup c'est comme normal d'en
bas de temps en temps alors c'est vrai
qu'on peut prévenir le même faire une
pause mais la tête par tafer le parti
qu'on veut pas de pause on parle tout le
temps mais on pourrait faire une pause
pub mais jusqu'à une logique d'essayer
de générer quelques revenus quant à
l'auteur de ce crime gratuit et tu payes
les intervenants
ce n'est pas le cas je veux dire pas
soit à l'argent qui tombe du ciel et
peut-être que ne pas faire plus
d'efforts ce que tu veux si tu as un
budget des bombes a offert avec quoi
donc de bon bah si tu veux prendre un
peu d'argent avec la pub énorme
ouais bah oui mais bien sûr bien sûr
nous défendons la pub non mais ok c'est
mieux pour tout le monde s'y est jamais
pu mais il faut comprendre pour bien
d'accord c'est pas par plaisir mais dieu
est bloqué il n'y a pas de
sandra les cantiliens ce crime gratuit
ça fait juste des cinq derniers mois il
ya quasiment deux semaines par mois de
live et tout le temps gratuitement des
bons équipages depuis peu de trois
minutes par heure c'est pas non plus la
revoir
ouais non puis c'est sympa la pub ça
tarde de voir un peu des nouveaux jeux
des mains tu du vôtre je tiens beaucoup
beaucoup mieux leur métier que des pubs
tient les deux qu'on dégage et là je
serais très mécontent que fout la pub
s'est arrêté pas de chance donc on fait
une pub et les gens veulent des pubs du
coup à fond faisons que du bas des
gaufres et que les airs et vous
intéressant on va découvrir des jeux les
des nouvelles séries sur amazon
un des trucs ça the boys yvon fin de
saison d'honneur à j'espère mais bon la
fin de la saison n'était pas terrible
non c'est une bonne idée de buzz on dit
un peu trop convenue discale est en
tournage
ok j'utilise je suis simple survie
stream final à plus de stream sur
châssis sur pias comme ray web en ce
moment là jusqu'en jusqu'à fin décembre
a beaucoup plus de ce crime sur chaise
comme france après en janvier et février
du coûtera plus de pub sur vise plus de
ce crime sur bitstream et après en mars
avec les candidats de nouveau de chasse
comme et donc peut-être par tous ok je
crois
jenny de trois parties puissent
continuer vas-y très tôt palau vient des
cinq bons sata sont pas besoin de tous
pour faire des 5 et 6 2 semble logique
et mars à 5 mois ouais watch quatre donc
et watchmen 5 surprend estimées à 8,1
bab à toi ici testé cinq projets très
tôt coloniale et au moins tu fais 6 500
perd dessin est ok je sais pas ce que ça
donne mais pas juste il sera hyper
content besoin arrivée très heureux il
va être admis il sue quoi sera
fantastique il va perdre quand l'une
merde
il va vers le sait les spas à fond quoi
j'ai encore sacrifier une qualité très
bien qu'ils habitent
c'est sûr qu'il va partir pour cinq ans
et wayne dès 5h 4 sinon c'est l'autre
option après je sais pas mais on peut
faire j'ai quatre points de suite pour
bloquer de façon tu fais quatre échecs
bon élève le roi a pas grand chose en
fait
séjour va savoir
c'est hyper dur à évaluer la 3g un petit
malin parce que tu échanges les dames et
heureuse mais tu as eu deux mois puis
vient le craypion passé denner bon ça
c'est vrai je sais pas à quel point en
mai a gagné mais il ya quand même plus
de chances face à la partie que le a5 ce
maxi liquide avance marc adjadj mais
total appui déjà il votre croix et 6 il
doit regarder déjà dès maintenant c'est
sur quoi il a les yeux qui pétillent
est ce qu'il peut faire j'avais 10 h 4
ans et fils quand même peut-être ce que
j'avais quoi
c'est quand même un coût colossal
extraordinaire est suracheté tu peux pas
prendre h la terre si aucun nom mais en
fait c'est enfin et un truc que j'ai
remarqué sait jamais si idiot que ça on
faisait juste gagner un pion cette fois
tu dises et des pions doubler ou quoi
mais c'est pas n'est pas un pion c'est
un temps ouais mais ça peut être
intéressant
maintenant je souhaite 27 mois j'ai
toujours le réflexe de ne pas les
prendre ses pions l'appui j'ai un peu
changé mon point de vue en tant qu'ex et
puis tu vois ce qui se passe après quoi
noms évoqués g4 a du sens aussi parce
que aussi tu tu laisses pas connectés et
fiable dans la finale ou quoi
donc oui c'est bien elle et pulsé
souvent les mêmes qui reviennent vrai
c'est vrai que ça c'est vrai parce que
moi-même qui regardent twitch souvent
les mêmes pub baba-moussa se demande
bien les esprits quoi c'est un peureux
vous
il est mieux le roi noir ou pas mieux
que qui que le roi plan j'imagine
durable livre ni mieux ni pire
guy en sueur y avons su avec une qualité
demandant mais bon guéris ou en croix
rouge ont regardé piétine moi j'ai pas
encore dire qu'il y perdant mais bon
arrive de tasseaux voilà nous qui
demande quand est-ce que ton cours sur
la pire que du coup va sortir
j'attendais ma première demi heure enfin
la double de mire j'ai envie de dire
j'ai fait en français et en anglais donc
la même chose on peut faire d'ici
quelques mois
ah non mais en coach compte finir de
tourner de ce qui l'attendait après
cessera ce sera une chaise qui mettra en
ligne qui mettra voie qui fera le
montage fait leur truc mais eux ils
soient ça que je pense aller d'ici fin
février
à mon avis c'est et merci à montana flex
qui s'adonnait avec switch prime merci
tonton wendy rio qui est pas super
joueur de faire un petit tour des stades
de mon côté so c'est bien navarre idc
est un peu longue
il a joué ses cinq ehpad et 5 et je sais
s'inquiète pas des saints ok
écoute c'est peut-être pas si idiot je
sais pas comment des 5 c'était
automatique
oui mais alors attends si si maxime
prend le pion c'est quoi l'idée c'est de
prendre un bel 6 j'imagine d'un premier
fils admettons aya tour sears is ok ok
j'en a compris l'idée déjà pas mal donc
en fait et si tu prends de la tour ça va
être la même chose ouais mais tu peux
pas faire d'apprendre ce qui à tour ses
six accords donc l'idéal est
compréhensible de prendre v6 cette
flambée ici c'est faire une double
attaque
et merci à ds galax us qui s'adonnait
avec switch prime merci tonton tu fait
plaise nationaux alors voilà et twitch
prime qui tombe et ben voilà les tontons
ça fait plaisir ça de faire tomber de
faire pleuvoir les prime là bas et c'est
cool ok gens achètent et les lignes un
peu le redis il te dit que h4 c'est
important et ne cherchent qu'à moi
j'aurais mes six maintenant les noms
mais chez basse et hg pour moi c'est
inquiétant dollars dit kim et moi la
chantera au regard de voir une veyron
que leur dit qu'ils regardent je pense
qu'il a calculé sa hache quatre tours
1re 6 ok c'est possible aussi agile
alban bon tu es obligé de bouffer sur
quatre intermédiaires tout rodez rodez 6
oui bon ça encore c'est chaud qui sait
peut-être s'est jamais vraiment mais on
va dire que tu joues le truc normal roi
prend et maintenant tu en prends les 6
12 ans je suis doit reculer on va te
prendre ici est ok c'est hyper chaud en
fait très chaud et fait j'ai une au
grain tout même les opus est clairement
en rival il dit battue je fais plus en
trombe et 6h tranché trois mois je crois
prochain dans le premier 6 dans ses six
ans une double attaque dame prend des
quatre dans le programme tout reprendre
on prend les sites il fait toujours
recette il assez content mais je sais
pas si je jouais sera de loin je les
volutes en décimant médecin de la tour
descartes attaque b4
si tu vois bien que maxime et que tu as
réussi à bien voir la position en tête
je pense qu'ils évaluent comme ça va
parce que défend comme en non c'est toi
c'est que tu attaques des quatre ans tu
peux pas faire ça et à tour beria f 6 en
l'air et ouais mais alors après faut
aller l'évaluer sa baisse vont partir de
loin mais possible que tu vois topalov
bas de loin tu dis oui mon bad as me
prends pas possible j'ai forcé 6 es tu
t'attends pas typiquement une pernik moi
je préfère dans mes calculs quoi tu
pousses pas c'est bien mais en tout cas
je pense que la maxi va je pense qu'il
va trouver max en fait t'as pas le choix
soit tu es vraiment mal je te fait
rouler dessus soit tu rendant truc
concret est bon c'est son style et
pioches madoff ski qui nous dit c'est ça
ma société m'a sauvé c'est mazzoleni 5
une bonne nouvelle la d5 ses proches de
1,0 à dessein que ce qu'on regarde avant
tout reprend ici c'est la fine avec
laurent qui revient au centre
c'étaient les cinq circulation le redis
ça faisait mal un battant mais si ces 50
c'est un gros problème mais là quand
même pas mal de réussite qui cette vente
qui sauve un parce qu'elle sort un peu
de nulle part
voilà mais je sais pas ces jeunes sont
souvent aux contrôleurs ses 120 c issue
un peu il ya un moment c'est très
compliqué et on écoutait repas l'offre
et merci alexis qui a lâché le switch
prime et ben voilà les tweets prime qui
tombe fable et which could have
aujourd'hui ils peuvent les twitts prime
on by pleuvent mais ces sacs en gros
quand même énorme il va falloir être bon
quoi ouais mais maxime grave maintenant
c'est à des partis qui sont sérieux ouah
c'est la bonne nouvelle du coup du coup
il est là c'est la bonne news parce que
c'est un peu chaud sinon de te suivre
ouais ça coûte on va voir c'est un
moment aussi h quatre jours
voilà mais bien sûr h4 jouer mais bien
sûr les amis mais bien sûr les amis on
souffle un on souffle on souffre on
s'occupe du coup c b tu dis ag où je le
rhum monroy rejoindre à bab el had chez
pas trouvé dans le top ça va aussi être
sage ans annoncé en fin de match quand
même te remets mon chien je sais pas ça
doit aller ça lorsqu'elle compliqué mais
le passé beaucoup de monde dix ans soit
chien en terme de clubs n'arrivent à
l'avenir sal à barcelos b5 tu veux carte
intermédiaire avec un truc un nouveau
coup mais oui je monte caisse est
clairement gagnant pour les noirs l'as
tu fais pour être franc je veux bien
croire que je fais d'année mais non mais
avant ça tout aussi juste toi à 3 tours
angers 3 oui bien sûr mais à
mais là c'est très bon on est passé on
est passé proche de la correctionnelle
quand même
et en plus on nous dit qu'il est pas mal
contre mam et que miyako benko en train
de résister à mam et non mis aucun match
3 en simple d'après max est favori mais
même les favoris
une formation que perdre un match oui
maxime qui va rentrer dans cette finale
c'est sûr enfin ça dépend si le choix de
l'autocollant parce que toi tu vas
détour quand même si c'est aussi une
arme et il a fait à séparer ses premiers
partants du coup c'est sûr qu'on entend
cette finale où ça peut tomber dans un
truc tout refus pions contre tours trois
pompes peuvent allemand nous passons en
a eu chaud comme souvent avec maxime
on est dans le dur mais maxime qui s'en
sort et qui s'en sort tout le temps au
fait c'est qui t'impose de deux joueurs
un haut niveau quoi
doerig tu tombes un peu il est là pour
te reprendre de volée ouais non mais
c'est la grosse force c'est la grosse
force de maximin cette puissance de
calcul impressionnante et sur roy prend
g3 d'un prendrait six tours c'est si
c'est quoi le problème
ah les cavaliers h 5 échecs wendy
topalov qui va être dégoûté un d'avoir
raté ça mais en fait je suis parti je
sais pas tellement dégoûté juste j'ai
moi même calculé mais c'est de ma faute
coincé par c'est pas un truc flagrant et
6,3 à chantal tremblay ci dessus et puis
on prend 1,5
bon en gros calibre
quel ordi g4 lui même formation
j'en prends tout rachid et simon tuke
shika de revenir sur f2 c
ces farc non mais rentrera final c'est
presque logiquement pour les mois contre
bon kenbé d'eau puisque m
elle trouve sa ferme une mais mettez ça
risque d une pièce de plus mais jenson
qui a pas vraiment de risque avant les
noirs non plus n'en basse a demandé un
coup de techniques peut-être si tu
considères bouchée des pions mais bon
pierre cas je crois se situe à finir en
taule contours maso qui lui dit il rate
beaucoup de ligne pat réduire le taux
pis dans l'eau dès l'ouverture c'est
miraculeux pour le moment m et 2 des 4
pièces avec un truc bonsoir que tout va
bien de max manger une bonne daurade ce
soir n'y avait que moi je dis toujours
quand on a la baraka généralement ça va
bien se passer
ça se passe bien non mais c'est un bon
tirage en soi topalov de toute façon non
si on peut pas mécontent que meiway
donc du coup grille tout cas remis ses
charentaises avec rick hughes en sueur
dame prend b61 rachetant la pro b 6
annonce son tour ses six c'est sûr
qu'elle veut ouais s'efforcer d'en
prendre quatre
cela me prendrait quatre enfants des
quatre résolutions et est donc le leader
des doors c'est juste attaque les pions
de beldame des blancs donc le jour où
tous les pions disparaissent le chou de
plus rapide trop significatif en
assurance même paquet noir soit moins
bien là franchement bayrou s'est bien
battu pour rien d'un nul probablement
ouais y'a une bonne nouvelle vu le co2
la partie évidemment ça rentre en un
truc un peu comme ça et on verra ensuite
on va voir c'est pas c'est pas encore
fait fab non ok sauf nuls avec ténors
quand hugh et guile toujours sur
constants l'état des partis non non mais
/ sipa femmes mais mais ça donne cette
impression surtout que h et de la
mauvaise couleur et comme dit à wral en
plus oui certes mais ça pourrait signer
nul assez rapidement d'ailleurs
et ben avantage pour andré kim contre 28
à saïx qui sera aussi une bonne nouvelle
du coup ouais ouais
les bonnes nouvelles si on aime il a
fait quoi maintenant sa viande riche
palmarès jouer à dota 2 où je pars non
mais je me demandais bien fait qui vous
suit a été finaliste de la coupe du
monde 2013 contre amis qu il allait
jouer les candides à l'époque est juste
il a plus bougé en fait ça on nous
répond bon espoir quoi tu pouvais
rejoindre le gratin est bon ça c'est un
bon jour à tout de même stats mais
j'aime ce qui est important c'est cher
mais il finit par un peu comme beaucoup
de ses joueurs qui finalement réussit
jamais devrait rester vraiment vraiment
à créer une bonne équipe de préparation
autour d'eux et qui est finalement un
peu comme un artemiev ou quoi qu'ils
aient du sens peuvent stagne en bas
peut-être un martin font corps et les
jeunes mais andré kling d'urgence et
stopper un voile et 22 38 mais alors
qu'il avait peut-être vingt ans j'ai
acquis ma paire super du jeu pas que les
jets avaient en 2013 mais elle était
douée un dimitri daikin une lan 90 donc
fait en 93 il avait juste 23 ans tu vois
tu veux candidats 23 ans était bien un
peu comme guy et louis saha les très
jeunes immigrés au moins ils quasi 2008
bon bref on fait mais juge argent qui
peut-il autre chose ça me prendrait et
magazines et vie de famille tranquille
où m mais au caisson dota 2 x ou night
club le soir et voilà quoi un peu de
faux faux et tu es bien quoi payet belle
vie non non non bien sûr passé mieux
vaut attendre à plus me desjardins et
mai car ce qu'il attaque mortelle il a
le droit mais non ça vous rejoindrez
qu'il est très talentueux
non mais sa petite vie tranquille sur
son petit pavillon non mais joue ce soir
je crois jamais vu avec sa femme
peut-être déjà papa ou pas quand on joue
à stockholm et bâle est maso qui étaient
là et puis vlad c'était son dernier
prendre un râteau aura forcément très
important a historiquement correctement
pour les échecs mondiaux
mais bon vivant nike inc y jouer sans
lui de prendre 5 kg 4 super et c'est
vrai que si fait des prochains qui
seront kg quatre ce serait beau cannes
enfin c'est peut-être pas possible de
s'offrir sa came non mais le problème
c'est que même si j'ai pas kg 4 et qui
fait des voyages 5 ou je sais pas c'est
quoi l'idée f1 et des souffrances
cachées car son nom mais en fait
pourtant un piège fait que tout une voix
en titre et ce plaisir ailleurs ça se
vit j'imagine que cette finale la n est
pas terrible pour les bleus enfin il va
faire annuler mais il est même pas mieux
qua non mais tout ça vaut mieux c'est
quelque chose mais je me répète mais
chic et en bas à droite et que moi qui
suis perturbée a fait c'est la partie de
clichy en bas à droite en fait c'est la
partie de ma mais je peux l'enlever
maintenant nous avons besoin d'air ça tu
n'es plus perturbé youri hurricanes a du
goût de commerce mic au switch rheinland
c'est pas m et je vends et riche prime
ça me donne envie de repasser vous le
délai sur les orientations très
intéressant je vais aller chercher à
isoler battant faut jamais prendre le
lien du coup petit plus pour les délits
sur le tueur isolé du coup boss et voilà
c'est une pub une autre genre le jeu
en fait c'est génial et puis tout le
temps en fait on devrait faire une
chaîne de pubs en fait métier qu'il ya
plein de gens je vois il met sur youtube
des vidéos il met que de la pub en fait
tout le monde aille ils disent oui mais
ouais je n'interdis ce truc ou passé 107
interne je sais pas en fait c'est
tellement chef de fer sac non
si l'époque paul faire ses choix je vais
le petit lien là oui on n'a pas parlé on
n'a pas parlé aussi de la sortie des
leçons en français c'est le moment ce
moment bah non mais c'est bon il ya les
100 125 leçon qui ont été traduites de
jazz comme en français pour faire passer
de 2 600 eloi 1000 1500 donc là j'ai
envie de dire bon bah c'est quand même
très très progressif très qualitatif
donc 125 leçon on démarre avec le
déplacement du roi ans filles avec des
doubles saks fith de fou sur l'europe
quand même c'est pas la base je double
sacrifices on va plus loin il m'a vu une
vidéo sur les émotions afin qu'elles
russian tu vas quand tu joues donc 125
le son avec des exercices des vidéos
donc 125 vidéos 125 125 tout quoi soit
un exercice fantastique mais il faut
être diamant pour savoir rester platine
t'as pas tout le temps quelques trucs ou
non ah ouais tu as quelques trucs mais
peut-être que jusqu'à 1000 deux croient
que plus tu monte en gamme plus il faut
être très bien par nous tous savons très
bien quoi déranger peuvent doute
moi je suis content je leur ferai des
petites vidéos en plus après donc qu'il
aille vers des nouvelles vidéos qui vont
sortir un peu la suite de a dit qin quoi
vidéo de leçons là et les kings veut
dire voilà la leçon se suffisent à elles
mêmes peut-être bombe après peut-être on
peut amener les gens de 1500 1600 2 on
verra de 2000 à 2005 et après 2005 à
3000 points après on prend même la de
commandes
ben oui maintenant que vous savez bouger
les pièces je peux venir
ce qui l'attend au pied mais pour jeter
ans et 6 ans parce qu'en fait va
peut-être y voit le problème est que du
coup il pu mieux mais quoi d'autre
donc là plutôt reprend si ça me prend
les quatre noms mais ils vont entonner
rentrer en force ou d'un prend tout
reprendre au repreneur six taureaux set
et après je sais pas s'il fait b 5 août
au rêve 3 pour les projets 3 quand même
elles feront combien les lakers sur la
perf heures d'ouverture bas ça dépendra
un peu du niveau mais de 15 euros
peut-être le plus faible tous dure une
heure une heure et demie a peut-être 45
50 euros pour les trucs un peu plus long
fabing ce sera la zone favorable à
fléchi souci si peu dur un package ce
soit répertoire entier ou si on les
décompose en 4 5 et 4 c 5 4 française et
karo kann donc pour point m6 d'encre en
d4 et bats la solution et hiller 3
septembre pour défendre avec 7
et c'est bien parce qu'on garde la tour
en des quatre actifs pour attaquer les
plus belles dames ouais non ça va faire
une petit nul niveau de jeu pas papa
impressionnant faveur dans cette partie
basse en fait le problème c'est qu'à
wilbon l'ouverture un peu dérapé pour
max est tout de suite tu trouves une
position passive ou t'as rien à faire
[Musique]
après que charlotte donc tu attends est
en fait juste qu'il a été bon au moment
où la fée du lait très bien calculer
quoi pour se sortir de ce mauvais pas on
prête au colloque aurait pu faire mieux
je vais différemment ça c'est une autre
histoire mais en tout cas c'est pas
comme si le boeuf était gagnant qu'il a
raté bien s'est il y avait d'autres
options de jeu qui avait l'art plus plus
embêtante mais je dois dire c'est simple
je peux comprendre ce qu'il l'ait fait
s'il voit son idée de torcé sisto axis
parce que juste du stop la ligne c'est
ce que maxime a pas prêt à lui il a
cherché à avoir couru avec dcb tour
c'est si c'est vrai que c'est l'idée
assez assez forte quoi
mais à bas pas de chance ça marche pas
donc sauf que c'est juste pas bon enfin
des cinq étaient beaucoup mieux mais d
un couteau réjouit tempo quoi oui mais
parce que fin mai en partie peut-être
4es et 5es parti j'aurais concertée
chiite et nous traiterons pdj en blitz
clairement je me pose pas la question
lui faire des 5 c'est ça je vais avancer
mais c'est vraiment des fois tu ton
positif est plus forte le coup quand tu
as fait chine mène peut-être assez
souvent
jones qui s'est sabordé du coup très
compliqué de jauger la forme est ce que
t'as pas l'impression masoch maxime
quand il ya beaucoup d'enjeu il a une
tendance quand même à ceux à s'auto
saborder ça c'est une vraie question au
pape un ou deux des tendances
suicidaires comme des rivales 5010
vraiment ça en fait donc
de quoi réfléchir ouais bah écoute être
un petit poucet 6 je sais pas quels
coups bas mais sa femme non ses six
pieds jeu parce que tu t'en prends mais
qu'as tu vas revenir en d5 et kung fu et
du coup tu t'appelles tu sais tu te fais
la caisse de porto roi et oui je sais
même pas si c'est un gagneur mais bon il
faut juste pas là dedans je veux juste
faire rus/kat et moi je me demande si ce
n'est pas vraiment les plans en fait qui
hérisse car vraiment non mais si tu
offert nul tu fais tourner froid tu joue
pas au con tu vas prendre g3 déjà mais
je prends à 4 face à 3000 ouais ça
m'inquiète pas beh moi ça me saoule au
rez-de-chaussée avec les blancs
personnes non mais surtout quand a été
tu veux pour le greffon avant donc la
l'a8 et paparazzi coche alors maso qui
nous répond je pense pas il est clair
qu'il est sur le toit le plus important
de sa vie mais il ya assez tranquille
non pas qu'il soit blessé cette fois là
mais je veux dire c'est lourd à porter
trois défaites en demi finale de coupe
du monde de mach fin mai après moi quand
je lui eus pas si longtemps maxime on
était juste renchérit il moi je me sois
tu savais très bien joué par les très
stressés qui n'en pouvait plus mais en
fait bien que souvent je sais pas de
voiture se passe mal à ce moment là mais
est ce que justement le fait de pas être
stressé c'est pas grave je suis pas psy
je suis ses os et aux psychologues
fabien les visages ski que je parle du
bien
non mais ok il faut passer sous cette
barrière psychologique aller aux
candidats se fera se traduit non non
clairement clairement clarens mais moi
je me demande parfois si le fait d'être
vraiment très tranquille c'est pas l'un
vers si tu vois c'est vrai c'est pas
pour pas prendre le stress j'avais déjà
raconté ce truc sur les sur les cosaques
qualité dans l'armée russe se délite des
cosaques tu ne pouvais pas avoir des
gens qui n'étaient pas père de famille
un peu plus un truc à perdre ce
qu'aurait dû tous utilisent comme a été
beaucoup mieux parce qu'ils avaient peur
de perdre quelque chose et du coup
peut-être le fais tu as d'être aussi
aussi détendu et enfin un toit c'est une
question j'en sais rien c'est pas au
contraire un insigne j'ai pas bon après
normalement oui tu te dis ce sont les
pas très vite j'ai laissé tranquille là
où des gens vont les autres se battre
donc du coup on sait on sait pas
fanniemorin sur level injuste pas
méchant ce que je dis c'est une question
en fait c'est une vraie question par
rapport à la gestion du stress est ce
que est ce que fait qu'il soit vraiment
tranquille ça dénote linverse ou est ce
qu'il est vraiment vraiment tranquille
fâchez pas s'effacer ça c'est une vraie
question
non d'après lui ce sont tranquilles je
pense d'après des photos des émotions
inconsciente ça c'est autre chose
ah oui mais ça peut être complètement
inconscient c'est pas obligatoirement
conscient mais c'est tellement bizarre
le stress comme truc en réalité il en
est aux intrants ouais mais bon là ça va
bien se passer pour la peine
donc alors tu reprends b4 torje
troistorrents à quatre ça à faire nul
bas atteint la zone après maxime doivent
aussi l'embêter globalement oui soit nul
mazovie oui je crois à ses yeux la seule
marque de faiblesse a été contre radis
les autres demis il a joué des monstres
à leurs attentes et voyait contre gries
tchouk deux fois il avait gagné une fois
d'ailleurs lots testés contre man et y
croit grandement ses forces eurent qu'il
veut battre magnus non mais pour le
début j'ai eu le coup de mou à mais
c'était grave n'est qu'une fois à rognan
est notoire est l'ensemble armageddon
par louis xv a contrario si pato
apprêtez à passer ça va larguer donc on
sait que tu sors de pile ou face
mézague pour mannequin soit je sais
qu'il était confiant de pouvoir lui a
collé mais non mais vous prêt on verra
un mais c'est sûr que ça ferait du bien
qui se qualifie voilà il a quand même
une grosse chance de se qualifier pour
la peine surtout surtout que mamediarov
et une épaule ils ont pas l'air ils ont
pas l'air ouf pour le moment non mais
bon débauche le skiffle m'avait lui fait
sa partie mais battu gagne pas la
demande ce qu'on tient quand même que
l'on fait et qu'est ce que je veux dire
mais quoi qu'il en soit avec max le mans
godet c'est qu'il a juste trouvé cette
entreprise atchicanon il fait une
figurine sur un duel mais tous les
autres joueurs du top 10 mondial perdre
aussi des parties importantes
oui et non tout le monde c'est le joueur
le plus fort actuellement sur le circuit
a pas être allé aux candidats de tous
les autres donc après il n'a pas eu de
réussite aussi dans les moments
importants et tout ça fallait tout un
tas de choses
non mais là aussi de ça compte
ok et là ça vient déjà de passer ce tour
l'ofs non mais ce qui me rassure en plus
c'est vraiment comme les autres sont pas
en super forme en plus ça t'enlève
encore plus de pression je pense ben
hammam et je sais pas en fait il n'ya
pas trop je cite aussi libre que la
forme c'est à cette partie avec les
blancs il n'a pas fait grand chose on ne
dit nulle signé wes est signée fabien
torcy seine et marne trois essais signés
chez max c'est bien c'est bien écoute
moi j il ya déjà une pub de signature de
partie déjà pour commencer de base mais
elle est là la pub de signature de
partie et après on voit ce qu'on fait
maintenant je trouve que ça je trouve ça
pas mal de faire c'est nul du coup de
main que les blancs il coûte il va pour
tenter sa chance en plus que nulle c'est
pas si grave puisque topalov un rapide
on sait que c'est pas c'est quoi sa
grande cadence
c'est un peu le même principe qu'avec
car monaco cam azoff ski qui nous dit
faut faire gaffe tu m'avais pas envoyer
du lourd mais thomas mais moi je suis
pas convaincu que ce soir mon copain
j'ai je sais pas fatigués de voir l
injuste car yaki de dépôt qui m'a l'air
moi ce que je te propose fab
c'est qu'on lâche pas l'antenne
immédiatement il reste treize coups dans
la partie mam et y accourent ouais je te
propose qu'on aille jusqu'au zeit parce
que il reste 40 minutes ok c'est quand
même ça me paraît quand même être une
partie
assez importantes dont on peut suivre le
design notes et puis et puis puisse
quitter à ce moment là oui mais aussi
ses côtes bagad plaignants oui oui si à
un moment donné ça mais sabine un truc
que les poliques roi quoi mais que moi
mais quand il chauffe il est chouette ça
c'est un mec qui marche à la confiance
et ciao maso peut-être à demain du coup
watts chacun sait le bonjour à max donc
donc donc à et sert à rien s'il me salua
tout ça pour ce qui compte ce maître
aminé non là ça c'est une pub
du coup je n'ai pas le temps pour armand
pour le moment c'est vrai que la
personne ça ça ne va pas revenir faire
dix mille pub et d'oubli surf ou qui
n'ont ce qui me sauve ce qui s'est passé
donc qui accompagne maxime à jérusalem
ni karachi surtout que ma mère est un
tableau plus accessible pas non à peu
près équivalent evolta c'est qu'andré
qui n'ont nous disait andré qui mieux
bon ça a l'air bon
égalisez pas symboliquement alors cette
partie avec ma mais avec les blancs fab
après juste je peux faire un petit tour
des stocks il ya d'autres trucs est-ce
que gears hyper dense que ça va alors
rien que des nuls il reste oui ighirri
des fonds pour gagner mais dur là-bas
hao wang hao hockey et tout le reste a
déjà fait nul en fait donc il ya
peut-être y avoir un fou nul aujourd'hui
comme rohff quoi l'ordinateur d'un
avantage blanc ici fab côté côté azéri
est ce que tomber deux tours à d'autres
princes au dessus ni de jeu 4 alors h4
on comprend l'idée c'est pour éviter que
les g5 je pense fab oui on peut qu'on
voit même pas en fait quelle quelle
quelle idée les blancs peuvent mettre en
place si tu veux bon parce que c'est
vrai que la une une nulle de manet
serait quand même une bonne nouvelle
aussi on aime on n'achète pas envie
qu'ils prennent deux points de bonus
j'ai pas envie de toi d'être dans une
situation à la con où il peut aller en
finale maxime brand minier
et mam est qualifié je voudrais éviter
ce genre de cas de figure je veux qu'il
reste peu plus possible à distance web
après le truc on n'influence pas trop ce
résultat quoi donc
après peut-être quelqu'un qui peut
glisser un téléphone portable dans sa
poche on appelle fatwa il ya peut-être
moyen de tu vois de moyenner quoi on
peut porter mais là non mais je sais pas
ce qui peut jouer un truc comme nos
ketura 4 courbet à 2 x 3 mai puis un
jour tu es prêt à faire qui est b3 tous
les gages la tour des quatre et je sais
pas d'avancer un peu comme tu peux
puisqu'avec à 5 c est ce que tu penses
que dans cette position il fait qu'il
reste 5 8 45 à iakovenko pour pour les
12 derniers coups ça peut ça peut être
un problème pour l'ensemble de ce que
t'as rien à calculer
mais oui si la maman il ya un truc
concret à faire c'est peu mais pour
l'instant je sais pas mais je vois bien
tourner ce qui pourrait essayer de
ramener son cavalier en d5
éventuellement ouais mais pas c'est
qu'il faut lui trouver un passage bon
vent voire d'y être 3 par exemple ou
bien ces 3 mai pour un centre doit
défendre tes pieds mais c'est pour ça
que le près de tours à 4 tours b à 2 x 3
et qu'elle ait faim qui a lieu trois
cahiers des cinqs aucune tu peux
peut-être
j'ai l'impression que yacco veut ramener
son calvaire des six noms pour toucher
les pions en tout cas calé g7 ça ça
semble indiquer nom c'est possible par
où justine recours
il pourrait aussi oui aussi il ya aussi
rajab à fond c'est pas vraiment de quoi
il est malade et s'il va vraiment jouer
les candidats il avait dit qu'il voulait
peut-être pas les jouer on ne sait pas
encore s'il va au candidat il est il et
il est malade mais on sait pas vraiment
ce qu'il a oui bon c'est vrai mais c'est
pas grave mais c'est pas forcément
bénard non plus quoi on n'agira pas
d'infos au sujet justement sable et ce
n'est pas à nous joindre sportif afin
que je le redis propose fois chez trois
rampes et chez cff cinq ans fait ok bon
sauveur chez son nom mais en fait c'est
que même sans faire trouvera quatre et
tout la même je veux faire je fais juste
pour ces deux cahiers fin qui est lui
troisième
mais si tu es fou h3 tu n'y arrive plus
non noté on s'en inquiète trois
intermédiaires machin passablement ce
qui va faire ma mère bon ben vous il
peut tourner ton qui venait pas encore
une fois je crois je suis curieux huit
noms vous viennent pour ces deux pays
d'ici le trophée f3
quel est ton jugement
[Musique]
car il est afin qu'ils aient 3 kg il
faut qu'on défende sekretev en c4 et
tour à quatre beaux spas et qui
éprouvait cinq tours à 5 fois 5 dont la
torah elle doit passer par mois sur la
colonne mais bon on vous donnera des
points forts du coup mais ce qu'on fait
flouer là tu faire quelques matches en
ligue les trois américains et trois
bogeys pour 120 peu de programmes mais
déjà c'est un petit début de trucs sympa
pour les banques
bref de re 3 peut-être voir parties à
redoubler tour sur adobe menacé ses
options à cet essai de cavaillé dia sont
des cinq points il ya des idées quoi oui
c'est plutôt ma mais qui presse ouais
c'est ça je pense que nul est favori
mais bon est ce qu'elle veut elle rejoue
ce soir demande mats maintenant il
rejouera demain à 14 heures il a joué
fois je crois justement on imagine qu'à
radio 8 fab
ouais je pense que ma mère va jouer
assez vite
c'est dans son style en décident met une
petite pression sur la pendule ouais
mais sans prendre le risque de flou non
vous en faites de premier grand prix de
l'année tiens tu as servi aussi
d'expérience il jouait contre auch à sac
le premier tour et il était beaucoup
beaucoup mieux les blés noirs mais en
fait il a fini par s'embrouiller et
perdre mais j'arrivais à + 1 53 points
et celui change quand même son destin
si passé ce premier tour on sait pas
jusqu'où ils allaient et c'est bien mais
du coup peut-être pu prendre des risques
comme ils prenaient de base à ces actes
avec le fou de ma mè est plus fort que
celui des accords ngor oui ils ont des
destins peu similaire sauf que
investissements - le rôle d'un pion qui
doit défendre à cet essai 5 avoir plus
blanc il ya déjà il peut menacer ces
changements le cavalier par ci par là et
ils passent devant la chaîne de pions
vers l'autre côté les tours noirs sont
meilleurs que les tours blanches
oui mais ça c'est éphémère parce que
fait qu'ils avaient trois jours bahreïn
comme on a vu dans la vente d'avant
fêtes mais le cavaliere peut être plus
facilité à venir le remplacer à avoir
c'est sa maison du couple que le taper
sur la route si bien sûr aussi c'est
quand même pas facile à percer à la pour
ma mémoire c'est pour ça que je conçois
nul c'est plutôt probable même si je ne
sais pas si c'est la qualité sur
cavaliers b3 je n'aurais jamais laissé
la qualité avec les noirs ici richard
hamelin qui ont des cartes mais bon de
toute façon
en gros tu le fais tu es obligée là tu
fais ça quand vous jouez pour le gain du
ciel font à l'ambition de le convaincre
et nord soit soit si vraiment le fait de
partir sur la catastrophe
et c'est pas tant ce à quoi s'est juste
où j'étais moins bien petit où on me
dise que la torah n'est pas un peu
coincé oui et non pour l'instant la
touche pas mais ça veut pas dire qu'elle
est nulle en fait et il est quand même
bien sûr le colloque scène ouverte pour
les blancs un jour elle bougera est pour
l'instant juste à point de la toucher
puisque si tu t'en vas tu doit empêcher
les x 5 donc tu veux pas 3 liée à le
contrôler quand même des cas
d'importante avec entre le terrain et
contre l'as ain qu'elle contrôle à cette
non c'est pas bloqués débloqués horrible
quoi t'est-ce me bloquait exactement
quand il va continuer ma mère
mais probablement et kf3 fouet fin pour
tenir tous les pions et pouvoir enfin
libéré le cavalier qui est pour le
moment vous est bloqué à la au simple
rôle de défenseur fring kling of clause
qui j'ai tout loupé mvl a fait nul
ouais il a fait nul et du coup il jouera
demain avec les pièces noires mais si tu
as tout le pire votre part une vidéo
rica valides dans un petit moment
donc tu pourras toujours et pour résumer
ce nom comme ça donc oui il a fait nul
en souffrent un peu mais c'est pas mal
il avait les noirs du coup de main y
aura le pièces blanches pas aussi de
pousser et quand bien même en rapidité
pichard quoi que touba sera grand favori
après après blessure solution du point
de bonus mais hélas non mais si tu peux
le prendre je le prend mais ça vaut pas
la peine de prendre le risque de sauter
non non il prendra pas le risque mais
géré par là que suivant ce que fait ma
mais c'est ce point de bonus il peut
être
oui mais la paille pas si anecdotique
en gros donc m3 monde avance sur ma main
avant de prendre un sac quand bien même
à mettre un point de bonus toujours
double dames enfin mais ça veut dire
après mam et passer un tour de plus
comme tu gagne deux points par tour il
te dépasse non mais j'en bastille en
fait man et gagne tous ses matches avec
bonus il ya le temps à la fin d'un bon
ok bravo métal droit aussi guinée 3
quand même ou pas ce que je veux dire
prendre un point de bonus un jour ta
mamie aux bagues et tous ses matches
avec bonus autant j'aimerais c'est vrai
mais j'ai vu si on peut réussir à gagner
demain
ah ben c'est évidemment jamais craché
dessus c'est quand même
ça peut quand même faire une grosse
différence
différence dans vos bras sans max a
gagné tous ses matches avec vos amis
quand il a perdu son époux gagner des
matches c'est frais c'est juste un bon
après il a perdu un départage contre mam
et avec les bons graphismes il a perdu
un match où on y pourquoi autant de
critiques sur lvl bah je sais pas quel
âge auquel les critiques parlent enfin
serment raison quand on est juste en
train de discuter de tout et de rien des
nuls des machins et c'est juste qu'on
discute des cas de figure des machins de
ce qui s'est passé de la partie de ce
qu'il faudrait faire
mais bon avec les blancs demain quand
même il sera il va pas freiner lundi
coup de main il va jouer mais ni à un
moment où marine at il faudra pas
forcément faudra parer ce qu'ils soient
tous gagnent mousse et super soit sinon
tant pis tu vois des parts and weight a
toujours ce moment un peu un peu
difficile quand elle est partie comme ça
et qui par un départage de dire c'est
peut-être moins risqué de prendre deux
parties rapides que tout jouer sur une
longue balle
surtout que rapide il est plus fort et
donc un audiencement voit pas grand
chose de la part de max avec les blancs
espérant qu'il est vide et prépare pour
ce tournoi mais je pense voit pas grand
chose quand tu comptes des joueurs
vraiment de premier plan après contraint
topalov je pense qui peut prendre
l'aventage en ouverture franchement ben
il n'y que bien évidemment et je pense
que les biens histoire c'était plutôt
bas rhin pierre coffin et de vos idées
je formule donc à rigueur et le dernier
stylo c'est hambourg il était midi la
finul et 2 mai il avait été la veille et
l'asie décisif dans les deux il fait
deux nuls cadeau parce que parce qu'une
vieille fille donc ils avaient mieux et
puis larmes a pas de cdi l'animal du
salon ah oui comme dit que c'était plus
dur des phares ans
mais pas donc je ne sais pas en fait un
de quoi ce qui nous raconte l etat les
critiques c'est pas dégueulasse et juste
enfin quand ça joue bien quand c'est
bien et où on le dit là en plus on dit
pas vraiment que ça joue mal juste on l
a souffert états unis c'est quand même
la vérité quoi donc si tu veux qu'on me
dise n'importe quoi par tout de génie
topalov a sauvé la nuance eu avec les
blancs on peut dire ça l'éthique n'est
pas très objectif même si tiger wood qui
nous dit honnêtement je vois pas comment
ma mais passe ici partout ouais bah
petit à petit toute heure bon bah disons
que là à court terme c'est pas facile on
peut imaginer un scénario lecavalier se
retrouvera en c6 par exemple s'annonce à
rien et que moi c'est clair brève sur à
7 mai dans le dans un lointain futur
en bouche c'est par là que tu peux faire
fin
ma position est la suivante trouvait la
touriste une idée c'est que il veut
faire car il y aussi ce don qui te
provoque fois je prends le retour en
fait la solution d'accord allait bien il
vient de faire foi je croyais bien de
faire toi et pour agir sur foot five a
fait retour des 6 janvier rejeté ce fait
je pense à ce besoin directement et non
non il a fait il a fait autour des 3
mais ça change pas des masses oisillons
pokam farfouiller fin autour des 6 ouais
mais de toute façon sur le rendent bien
moche trois maïs que funny story vont
croire de obligé d'embaucher
si on joue bien cavalli acheson dans son
salon de kanifing du coup tu pars avec
ma maison je sais rien des fouilles et
les qualifiant ce sont 26 longues étapes
dans des doc et enfin esprit 's&p mais
ça on peut peut-être espérer gagner tu
veux essayer de jouer après le mauvais
flou c'était un très mauvais faux m
ça peut être long mais ça peut passer
pendant qu'on voit un peu le scénario ou
mamediarov pourrait pour obtenir quelque
chose mais bon ça veut pas dire ça va
gagner pour autant mais non mais ils
peuvent avoir à il peut avoir l'idée
d'avancer quoi des blancs peut
exactement deux cavaliers enfin
cavaliers trois cavaliers des cinq en
gros le plan lorsqu'on y arrive c'est à
dire que ça va l'emporter mais on n'est
pas bloqué à ne pas bouger
c'est sur deux rangées c'est ça donc mam
équipe away qui peut essayer qui peut
équiper c'est vraiment ma vie là il a
tout intérêt quand même à fabas à la
tournée le plus longtemps possible avec
avec les blancs réponse d'apple
tout à fait surtout que le point de
bonus et facial tic tic
mais lui il doit vraiment être à la
course aux points bonus ce qu'il a du
retard en fait il est 3e avant la
compétition
max je tort sa différence juillet second
il a quand même une matelas donc il a
pas besoin de prendre tous les risques
bons baisers sur 6 or tous les risques
c'est un grand mot ce que je dis mais il
doit quand même
la situation est plus délicate sous de
maxime après s'ils m'avaient gagne le
tournoi donc quasiment tous les cas de
figure il
bah oui c'est là autant de points de
bonus que maxime s'il gagne le tournoi
il même si maxime voir en finale il se
qualifie parce qu'il ya trois points à
prendre et en tournoi est plus
importante que l'instant affronter des
points oui bon ski oui ce qui est
logique
ouais bah faut bien un mode de
départager quand même le mode le plus
logique j'ai envie de faire donc rude
aux cavaliers ou six comme on l'avait
dit et donc ici peut-être fou prend 1,6
mais on avait notre position ouais nan
fr après les fuites mais fou prend une
scission points du 6e se dépatouiller
par tour à deux claviers fin et pour des
deux sacs à mettre un petit plus pour
les blancs à sa non merci on déloge pas
les tours s'en débarrasser en fait le
caviar j'aime bien sexy ben tiens pour
illustrer fait des tours trois des
quatre est aujourd hui le d4 est
complété par des deux encaissés 4 en
l'air ils sont fous même si ces
changements pas tout ce que tu veux
croire coup droit et que les blancs
prennent et que tu prends d'un pion
férois détroit aux caisses en tout
espèrent y gagner parce que la tour
noire elle est passive
on va avancer nos options on est petits
cavaliers j'ai pas fais des choses quoi
on va peut-être mettre la tour en asie'
visqueux qui avait rassemblé dans cette
île je sais pas on va tourner et je peux
pas dire si c'est gagnon bas mais je
vois que c'est possible
après si jamais on a même cas de figure
est une tour noire active c'est quand
même pas ce qu'ont pu dire sur quelque
chose puisqu'à la tournant elle va
rester dans notre camp et va nous
empêcher de ré on vous attaque des pions
le faire des échecs afin et donc donc
c'est pas tout à fait cependant les
normes menace paca et des quatre pour le
moment pascal à tour des trois
entreprises
oui donc en fait très clairement il ya
moyen de jouer un coup de consolidation
mais encore trouvé
il reste douze minutes pour jouer huit
coups dans une course pas même à notre
mât mais à notre mamie ou à leur mât
mais plutôt et yako yacco qui joue
peut-être un peu aussi pour protéger on
est paumé une époque qui m'a pas l'air
d'aller chercher quoi que ce soit en
tournoi bon je croyais qu jours donc je
suis obligé de choix quoi ya pas de
rougeurs avec moi non mais habile
bon ben on s'adresse à tous parce que ce
sont les taureaux attractif iakovenko
qui kiffent abba des mini films signés
vois tu vois pas de point de bonus
attend il reste la partie de demain mais
oui ça semble pas mal parti puisque je
pense pas qu'ils aquos envoie en l'air
avec les blancs non non non oui non il
ya coutu pas se passer comme ça avec les
normes mais du coup j'ai envie de te
dire c'est une première journée révèle
finalement pour nous puisque maxime avec
les blancs les noirs par du fémur
les autres sont nuls avec les blancs
donc bah écoute pour le moment maxime
qui ce qui se rapproche petit à petit
son objectif ya eu nulle part tout vote
à 5 andré keane ça va faire nul aussi
c'est sûr juste avant de vous quitter
navarra où angao ça va faire un nul
aussi et/ou et ighirri donguy qui va
peut-être être le seul perdant de la